it's 10 o'clock welcome commissioner
so um before we get into too much of a
formal
presentation um I'd like us to look at
507 and
um what you can see here is except
possibly for federal funds it looks
really good right because on paper it
looks like we're going to be spending
we're we're we're allocating um roughly
the same as as was spent in fiscal year
2024 which is kind of what we need um so
that looks really good um before I get
to the next comment let's let's just
talk about what happened to federal
funds uh thank you and so for the record
Helen Hanks commissioner of the
Department of Corrections to my right is
Lisa Stone our director of
administration and I'll let her triage
that sure um so if you go to our handout
on page three I kind of um look at that
so what happened is in fiscal year 23 we
had significant arpa expenditures and we
actually received that Revenue in 24 so
it understates our fiscal year 24 spend
what would have typically been General
funds so if you take into account for
that and then we did actually have about
a half a million dollars in arpa
expenditures that we didn't receive
revenue for in 24 in addition to about
$100,000 in other Revenue under other
funds so when you net all of that out in
the correctional Industries loss our
general fund spend should have been
about 169 million 701 okay all right so
basically um this wasn't like you got a
Federal grant specifically to do such
and such this was the state redirected
some of their arpa funds to you which
replaced General funds at the time is
that kind of it was for um essentially
Recruitment and Retention incentives
that were paid in fiscal year 23 Revenue
received later but if you hadn't had the
federal funds and still did that work it
would have been General funds yeah
that's correct if the initiative was
funded through General funds you're
correct okay so then so that looks great
but going into the the main
budget I'm I'm worried that what we see
is not
realistic because what we see there is
all the overtime lines going to zero or
near zero and the the full-time lines
having more funds right but
traditionally you haven't worked that
way right you've had tons of overtime so
I'm worried that what we're what's
actually in the budget that adds up to
these great numbers isn't right so let's
talk about that yeah thank you for that
question with the footnotes that we've
asked for which would allow us to take
the funding from vac positions that are
not filled those filled positions would
reduce the overtime and continuing to
use that methodology um that's what
we're leaning into and then to your
point if that's not enough so if things
that we can't forecast today happen uh
some increased number of retirements or
a decrease in recruitment there we did
add the additional component that we
would come before fiscal uh for an
additional request or appropriation that
isn't otherwise funded through the
vacancy Lines within the agency trying
to use what has been a tool in the past
but then also uh recognize we will
potentially need a safety net again for
things that we didn't forecast uh that
happen in three years from
now yeah so do you really think well so
let's talk about recruitment so how many
people are working now versus two years
ago so there in the enforcement ranks
which uh strike us the most we have a
42% vacancy rate whereas we had a 50
what did I send to you the last time a
[Music]
mic it's on this page 51% vacancy rate
so we had a 51% vacancy rate in January
of 2023 in those lines of effort and now
we have a 42% vacancy rate in December
2024 and that rate is still current uh
we have uh 28 new officers going to our
next Corrections Academy uh that's a
wonderful number to have um and the
track it is and the tracking and
trending of our recruitment to date even
when I gave you um I'll show you the
graphic uh this graphic I had 30 new
hires now I have 33 um and I still have
more coming so that is a wonderful
number for the Department okay so our
recruitment efforts are working uh we
need to continue to lean in our
retention efforts again I don't uh
control the retirement decisions of the
state those will obviously potentially
impact this agency um and uh and I do
think this is an appropriate strategy
given the state of the uh finances of
the representative
wer dug out the piece that came from the
uh treasury the number of paychecks that
were actually issued and I'm looking at
a year they were like January 2024 820
then it went gradually up 830 850 88 so
you've been gaining all most most of the
last year thankfully we ended up with
848 last December paychecks so yeah we
we have other ways of tracking this yeah
but people that don't want to tell us
the real vacancies oh I appreciate the
validation sir thank you you're welcome
so
is I don't know 40 hours of a of a
full-time and 40 hours of overtime sort
of roughly the same cost because a
full-time person you there's a whole
bunch of benefits and overtime is like
double time or something so therefore
it's kind of a wash more or less is that
true or not really I would I would defer
I I'm going to suspect but I'll defer to
her that the overtime costs more but so
it takes about 11 months to break even
if for a new H verse um using overtime
so so and it also depends on the new
hire if they're the family plan for
health insurance um single single are
you just saying because a new hire is
unproductive is that what you mean or I
mean all I mean they're in training and
all this sort of stuff right it's there
it's the certification process getting
them fully individualized and certified
well that's not quite what I meant I
meant um just assume it was you had a
full-time
person right so a regular full-time
correct officer of the same level as
somebody working overtime right is is
the cost
of
um is the cost per hour of the regular
full-time
person sort of similar to the cost per
hour of of that overtime
hour so it I mean the hourly rate is
double and the benefit rates on overtime
is going to be the same it's just really
the health insurance is benefits charged
per hour is that yeah um for retirement
in Medicare gotcha so so it's worse so
overtime is worse yeah yes okay it's 60%
benefits so you know so that's what I
didn't realize because I
thought in in my industry right if you
work overtime you only get salary more
you don't get more health insurance or
something right so it's
right so anyways go ahead repres
representative camell thank you Mr chair
So based on that strategy how many
vacant positions would you need to leave
open to cover all the overtime uh in a
typical year I know that you won't know
I appreciate that question actually the
goal is to fill those so that we don't
uh need to lean in on overtime so we
won't do an attempt to hold things to
fund overtime our goal is to recruit
people so we don't use overtime I think
the other part I would share uh just for
we've been tracking again I we look to
this page I'm showing it to you
graphically the cost per hour so we
understand what we've uh the cost in
2024 and then the cost in 2025 and so
the number of hours does costs more but
we're also tracking how many new people
we bring on so again it's it's a
multiple faceted strategy and then I did
share with State fiscal for those that
sit on that um committee the other area
that we do uh lean into is to reduce the
number of people appropriately to Public
Safety that are actually incarcerated
and so from the perspective that we've
reduced our recidivism rate by 8% over
seven years that's 200 less people that
are incarcerated and so that has saved
the state approximately using the right
number representative McGuire uh4
million over seven seven years so it is
both a recruitment strategy but also a
for those appropriate individuals uh to
try to keep them in the community and
under community supervision at $2 a day
instead of $250 plus dollars a day thank
you you're welcome okay so um let's talk
about uh numbers of of um so that you
keep a track of both inmates and number
supervised right is that the way you
think about it well sure yeah and and so
the inmates are roughly 2100 Today is
that they're in custody in the state of
New Hampshire
is
1,970 is in uh inmates in our facilities
and then supervised out in the community
under probation and parole is just over
4,000 there's a higher probation case
load than parole case load um and those
are by factors of the Judiciary okay
yeah I wasn't sure if the if the 4,000
included the 1900 or no no they separate
okay so total of close to 6,000 right
that we are responsible for the state of
New Hampshire gotcha and um the the 2000
number or 1970 is that that's a little
lower than it was two years ago yes is
it it is from two years ago it's been
static the last two years I would call
it static um so we are leaning into the
why is there anything we can do
differently to help that number reduce
uh several years ago at the point in
which I saw a natural uh major decline
because at one point we had 20 700
people uh in the facilities and now when
you compare that from 2010 and 11 to
where we are now uh I afforded the
opportunity watching population
reduction to shut down a whole second
floor of our largest uh general
population unit and so that saves us 14
posts we don't fill every single day
right yeah and I was thinking that um
the population's still aging so we would
expect crime to be decreasing right so
you know yeah I'll I'll let the national
statistics speak for itself New
Hampshire is rated number one both in
safety and in Corrections for the work
that we do here and it's both for the
reduction of violent crime uh and the
reduction in our our incarcerated
population there are numerous National
Advocates talking about a rise in
incarcerated populations across the
country and we uh shine in a good way on
that map as ours is not um increasing at
the rate other states are and I would
say that again under former Governor
suoo we didn't engage in Mass releases
during the pandemic we kept people
incarcerated and safe and we ranked
number two for best outcomes both for
wellness during incarceration and
wellness for our staff we've done an
amazing job on behalf of the state and
very proud of the work that we do with
the Department of Corrections
congratulations yeah very nice
um so but possibly the recession is
causes more crime is that possible
represent McGuire I think we can we can
uh look different things like that it's
I mean so one one aspect is pushing
things down and something else is
pushing it up some MERS of my team that
have been with us for 20 uh plus years
look toward a recession because they uh
believe it will increase our recruitment
so there are a lot of factors we look at
when the economy becomes a okay now in
terms of your overall budget what
fraction is for the incarcerated
population and what fraction is for the
supervised population so
you're talking about if I pull out field
services for our overall budget
percentage Yeah I mean let's call your
budget 165 million a year okay so is it
100 for the incarcerated and 65 for the
for the I mean you know you'd have to
split your time a little bit and things
like that but I mean I'm just in in the
big picture kind of I appreciate that
question I've never formulated what that
would look like as a percentage
um and I'm happy to get that back to you
I think right now I would be I'd be
throwing a dart at what that represents
because I know that being under
Supervision in the community is $2 a day
and so representing that 4,000 costs $2
a day and then knowing 40% of of the
inmates in our facilities today are back
on parole
violations so that's important
information it used to be 40% 40% it
used to be 48% now it's 40% so as we can
decrease that percentage again balanced
by safety we wouldn't do that just to
save money we would only do it if it was
a safe choice that makes a difference so
800 of the
2,000 are in parole violation yes of
varying types whether they have been
under parole and engaged in new criminal
activity that has both brought them back
in their pending charges or it's uh
repeat non-compliance with their parole
uh requirements and you said that's
lower than in the past 100% it's 8%
lower than 7 years ago I see what about
nationally nationally we are under the
50% standard there are some states that
uh I wonder what their measure is uh for
measuring recidivism they tout a 2%
recidivism rate um I don't want to
disparage my counterparts but I'm just
not sure where that comes from
represented
months thank you Mr chair
um the um
where do you have the biggest issue with
um recruitment is it for uh the staff
that supervis that are in charge of the
supervised population or the inmate
population it's the inmate population uh
is that where most of the people are the
inmate population they're the most
expensive okay so I would share with you
that there is a normal career path
progression in the department to become
a corrections officer and over the time
promote into a paration PE officer
whenever we have a vacan and our
probation appr Pro ranks it's filled
very quickly okay what what is I mean to
to following up on um representative
McGuire's uh question do you have any
sense of what the split is in terms of
headcount in terms of how many people
are working in the um you know
supporting the uh the supervised
population versus the incarcerated
population yes there are 77 of my 48
existing law enforcement positions 77
are supervising people in the community
it's much smaller number so to give you
just a breakout I have seven different
unions the teamsters represent the
Corrections Officers and corporals that
equals to about
274 law enforcement officers and then
the sca sergeants and above are roughly
a
100ish um and then it there are some
that do not belong to unions like my
majors are uh not in a union but gives
you a proportion and then the 77 I
represented 11 of those are chief
probation approle officers they have
their own Union and the de Delta is in
the probation approle and just one last
question um go ahead yeah just one last
question so that I hear correctly that
when you're hiring people you're hiring
them as enforcement officers and then
parole officer is a um kind of a
career uh step for them you don't hire
you don't hire new parole officers
that's correct sir thank you do do uh
probation officers work less overtime
than the others or is everybody more
less the same so the difference for
probation PE officers their choice to
work overtime is voluntary they do uh
provide augmentation um uh and our
Corrections Officers and corporals and
so on there is both forced and voluntary
overtime gotcha yeah because I know this
$2 a day doesn't sound right to me
because um you have 4,000 officers $2 a
day would be less than $1,000 a year so
we'd be talking $4 million for that out
of$ 165 right so you know it's it's got
to be way more than that if you just
think about it in terms of one sixth of
the officers are on parole and probation
then one six of the budget would be more
like $25 million or something like that
you see what I mean I hear what you're
saying um understand how you're getting
there I I want to be more prepared to
answer your question all right right
I'll let you think about that yeah I was
trying to get to the which page was my
field services
budget
489 yes that's 77 probation and
officers there you
go okay yeah so 15 million divided by
4,000 is is $4,000 each not
right so it's more like $5 a day or
something anyways okay very good so um
it's still of Lo
number incarceration yeah yeah and bear
with me that $2 is from my fy22 annual
report and I'm going to be surrendering
the FY 23 soon and then the fy2 24 in
synchronic so I'm getting all caught up
all right let's ask um I any other sort
of general questions from
than thank you um I I see in in in in
your budget and I don't think it's
Unique to your budget but there is about
200 $2.4 million in FY 26 of what are
called current expenses what are current
expenses those are our our class 20
expenses paper pens those disposable
items they're under by State uh manual
procedures and Department of
administrative Services Under 240 $9.99
or less are considered current expense
so that's the new way of call saying
miscellaneous yes okay anything over
249.99 is considered equipment so you
see that in class 30 they probably have
a lot of paper cuffs and things like
well to your point there are different
consumables within the correctional
institutions we are literally trying to
reduce physical paper but representative
evil thank you Mr chair so you said do I
does anyone have any more general
questions I don't I know if this meets
your definition or not okay but um I
read before we get to the page yes right
I read an incredibly uh comprehensive
two-part series of articles on Indigent
Council representation in the state of
New Hampshire and so I I guess I'm I
appreciate being on division one because
I understand what a huge there's so many
threads that make up the sweater right
yes so one of the comments um in there
was that the number of incarcerated
people really can track back to what is
considered a Class A or B misdemeanor
and what is considered a felony I mean
would you say that was a fair statement
I think that's uh statutorily makes
sense yeah and so one of the things that
they were saying as far as our system
and I'm not arguing one way or the other
I'm just making a comment like what was
in there for simple possession if you
moved it from a Class A to a b or a B to
an a I don't know which way it is it
could really affect the whole system and
the processing of the claims and the
other thing is that simple POS I mean um
for felonies for theft right now it's
$1,000 to become a felony and if you
moved to 1500 or if you moved it to
2,000 you could also change the
incarceration rates so I'm again I I'm
not arguing one way or the other but I
think as we sit here recognizing this is
this huge package and incarceration
rates costs are so much higher than some
of these others tweaking things way out
here can make a huge difference like way
out here and I know on possession I
assume they're talking about marijuana
uh you know and how they but would you
say that's a I know you're not arguing
one way or the other but would you say
that was a fair statement representative
anytime the state adjusts statutes to U
I would say adjust a felony to a
misdemeanor or uh even down to a
violation and a fine those uh clearly
affect the use of the New Hampshire
Department of Corrections and that type
of incarceration and then in carefulness
and again I do not oversee County jails
when you adjust something to a
misdemeanor you would be having that
person serve incarceration potentially
in a county jail if they're not on
probation as a
diversion thank you you're welcome I
that was General yes good no and I I I
would tend to agree with you and I I'm
willing to bet that that ,000 cut off is
really
old like we're talking about when fines
are
set yeah so I know you do a lot of
training when you have them in prison I
know that you have your own
saou um so there's probably a major
portion of the inmates that don't don't
have a high school diploma and maybe
they get it through their I know you
have carpentry and and autoshop and all
that what do you think is the most
successful program in perhaps stopping
the recidivism is it getting the high
school diploma is it getting the
training or can is it hard to tell
represent wer I would tell you that
nationally when they look at what makes
the most profound difference providing
somebody with a base education is the
first foremost thing you would do and
then you'd layer on again vocational
skills because most individuals are in
need of those for that success what
percentage do you think come in there
without a an a diploma I would tell you
that on the uh men's side I don't have
the exact percentage but a larger number
of them have not completed their High
School level of education on the uh
female side a lot of them have uh
completed their Base education and for
them it's postsecondary and Vocational
skills thank you you're
welcome repres just to follow up on that
and and Mr chair this follows up on a
conversation we had in here I don't even
know what day it was anymore but I
worked a lot on dyslexia and dyslexic
education and early screening and one of
the things that we found to support
trying to do better with dyslexia was
something like 20% or 25% of the people
that were incarcerated had very had
learning disabilties
that sort of threw them off the path
forward um which was just I mean it's
probably higher I just don't want to
exaggerate but just emphasizing the
importance of uh early intervention and
and educational support and to your
point I would offer that we not only
have to comply with the special
education standards but we also offer
that um the other uh issues around
learning disabilities in education that
don't meet the special education
standards for the students people who
inmates who are getting Education
Services uh if I could sir I do want to
point out the other reduction we
consciously made was approximately $1.3
million in contracted services for
forensic evaluations uh we are not
statutorily required to provide those
Services um and so in order to meet uh
the target we did take that out of our
medical budgeting line ex what is is a
forensic in evaluation what do you mean
so those are the criminal competency
orders that come out of the Judiciary uh
the statute speaks to the ability for a
defense Council to question criminal
competency in cases when that comes
forward then it is the charge of the
prosecution to uh essentially uh negate
that claim and the judge then orders a
criminal competency evaluation the
statute
13517 speaks to to the education
standards of the person who would do
that in our state but does not create an
office of forensic examiners it also
does not bound it to the Department of
Corrections it is simply a contracted
services that is an archive of moving
the secure psych psychiatric unit to the
department in the 80s um and we're not
going to continue to fund that in the
next bium budget in this budget proposal
but on the other hand I noticed on page
496 you're adding five more people to
Mental Health
or
six yeah I definitely not adding uh
competency so I have in that
line am I looking at this use you tackle
that so um it's actually just
transferring positions from other
accounting units so we had an executive
secretary that moved from accounting
unit
3373 a recreation therapist that moved
from accounting unit 5833 and then we
had an admin a clinical mental health
clinician and a nurse I can't hear you
very well because You' be a little CL
and then we had three positions that
moved from 8234 so if you refer back to
those sheets you'll see there's changes
in those position
counts so it's not a it's not an
addition we've moved people to different
organizational units to account for
where their service is delivered within
the department oh I see yeah but they're
within this mental health uh accounting
unit no the contract money the 1.3 will
show up under uh class 101 and not as
Personnel lines because they're not
state employees there would the state I
think would be challenged to hire a
forensic psychologist or forensic
psychiatrist given the unique uh Niche
uh career costs of
those right but I so say again why
this went from 24 to
29 we
moved one two three four five people
from different accounting units into
this accounting
unit right so from the secure
psychiatric unit you move
to from the rehabilitative services you
moved one Etc right yes yeah and we have
in the past if it helps the committee
sent you those transfers in a separate
spreadsheet happy to do that okay but
just you think you need more in this
area for some reason yes we just shift
so sometimes what I find represent
McGuire chairman is that they've been
sitting in another county unit
performing the service for this unit and
this is clean up
time okay all right so let's go back to
page
473 um what is victim
Services yes victim Services we have by
Statute uh our own Bureau of victim
services to support individuals affected
by felony level crime so on any given
day we're supporting more than 2,000
people who have been affected by the
crimes of those incarcerated in the
state of New Hampshire a majority of
this funding does come from Voca the
federally funded um it's been four
decades uh Across the Nation
and they provide both support for
individuals who are coming into our
Institution for parole hearings against
survivors and victims of crime felony
Statute so are you really going to get
an extra whatever it is
140,000
120,000 per year from the federal
government for this so um the majority
of that funding is to fund two positions
they're partially funded and there was a
vacancy so in speaking with New
Hampshire Department of Justice they did
estimate that that would be what our our
um Revenue would be and that is kind of
what we would have expected in fiscal
year 24 had we had that position filled
so the Department of Justice is
basically transferring you this money
for this thing is that it yes they're
The Entity that receives the federal
Voca dollars and then they award those
okay but you're adding three 150,000 of
general fund
also on page 473 yeah um the general
fund for fiscal year 24 spend was 355
and then it kind of
job there's a significant amount of
General funds too there is there again
there are 2,000 plus people we provide
support to that come into the
institution the position allocation had
included an administrative support
person who literally physically mailed
out notification when we went to the
automated it's called Vine victim
information notification system we
learned that we didn't need that
executive role anymore but we would
benefit more from another victim witness
specialist who literally helps people
prepare both what they want to say at a
parole hearing to their perpetrator and
um helps coordinate bringing them in so
they feel safe we are interestingly
unique in that our um parole hearings
the victim has to sit in the same room
with someone who may have sexually
assaulted them and not and this far away
um so having another victim witness
specialist to help support that process
really is the right thing to do so we
only have two victim witness Specialists
to do that work now and one is um being
recruited for as we speak so you think
in including the victims in this way has
some
rehabilitative effect is that uh it is
are charged by Statute to provide
appropriate support to victims and
survivors of crime felony level crime uh
I think it's a good safety planning for
for individuals it also helps educate
them on what the actual process is so
they come in incredibly well informed
most people don't anticipate that
they're going to have to understand how
to navigate the criminal justice system
let alone the complications of the
correction system um and that's what
these two full-time employees uh one
right now and two in the future will do
I mean presumably they want to be there
right I mean some people are nervous but
they want to have their voice and they
don't know how to do that without
feeling safe um we have there are a lot
of strong confident people who want uh
and come uh even angry and we have to
actually coach them on how to present in
a way that they're going to be heard and
not just sound angry and I don't mean to
be insensitive but we want people to
literally have uh the right voice in the
room especially in parole hearings and
release hearings interesting
representative EV well I was just um
remembering our discussion with the
attorney general yesterday that he had
something nine something million dollars
to in general funds in his budget that
the governor had put in because we were
losing Federal Appropriations do you
remember the Voca so so part of the
money then would be coming to you from
the right that's my understanding
H all
right okay um so the next one I wanted
to talk about is Correctional Industries
page
479 so this one
anticipates um like an extra million of
income
over what you actually got in
accurate uh we we essentially just uh
flat funded it from the from fiscal year
25 is adjusted authorized um and so I
think what made the difference up was
vacancies at the time and some um fan
right in our ear can't hear sorry so
it's it's a you want to turn that off
maybe I don't care but if she just gets
closer to the yeah right sorry um so
it's essentially flat funded for fiscal
year 25's
ask right but I'm this is money they're
they're selling stuff right or they're
doing services or something correct
right so wouldn't it be more accurate to
to have something closer to what the
actual in this case
[Music]
yeah I potentially um I mean the are you
expecting the the the activity to to
increase by 20% is you know I would say
it is fair that we forecasted new
vocations and new opportunities in
Industries we are hopeful that we will
take in more Revenue we've increased um
and invested in um Printing and uh
marketing resources we've also invested
more in our sublimation work that we're
doing so that we can actually sell and
produce goods and and re really
reinforce both uh budget neutral but
again revenues uh for this particular
area it's Unique obviously to the work
yeah this furniture yeah and all the
signs we see yeah they produce most of
the signs and some of the towns that
want a special sign town beach open such
and such a lot of them are contracted oh
yeah I mean I place I have in my house
some great things that they've made you
know so but my my my main point is if
you look at 2024 you'll see that there's
243,000 of General funds and that's
going away in future years so I'm
worried that if these agency income
doesn't materialize then you're going to
come back to fill in with General funds
because you want to lay off any of these
22 people right so and I hear you and we
also requested a footnote because those
positions uh are funded by their revenue
they're motivated to make this money
because that's another uh incentive
okay um anyways I guess that's more
for anyways you understand the concern
all
right um represent month thank you um
the uh I understand that the inmates are
are paid a small stien for their work
doing this uh this this work where does
that show up in the budget sir uh
anywhere you see class 68 remuneration a
word I've practiced saying out loud for
years that's that's that thank you
you're
welcome
okay all right so most of the rest of
the stuff is the thing we talked about
overtime versus
full-time um I guess guess why don't we
so let's see here
486 equipment yeah so you're you're
planning
on
um what is this congr contractual
maintenance
buildings and grounds
242,000 yes one area of business I
learned as a department that we did not
have a uh called kitchen grade cleaning
contract for our kitchens U this funds
those contracts so it is to make sure
that our Public Health inspected
kitchens meet the standard of Sanitation
we do have inmates who clean on a daily
and regular basis but that's what these
uh increas Es are the result of we had
not previously had any regular uh
commercial private entity who knows how
to clean those kitchens to meet those
standards come in and the inmates can't
be trained to do to that level or uh
it's also the equipment that they bring
in and and the and the venting systems
and the grease traps and so again the
inmates do clean the kitchens this is to
assure that we meet our Public Health um
inspection and we've been uh doing it uh
this year and we just want to be mindful
that we've been basically essentially
choosing not to do other things to make
sure those kitchens are clean oh so the
fiscal year 25 number is not really zero
correct I see okay all right
[Music]
um oh let's go to page
499 and I saw this in two
so see on page 499 uh class
100 there's a big decrease $3 million in
prescription drug costs from actual to
to budget it so is that
realistic uh I think that's a fair
question we've been uh implementing the
re-entry 1115a waiver with that we've
received as a state from the center of
Medicare Medicaid services we have a
pilot occurring where 45 days prior to
inmate's release if they're eligible for
Medicaid and 90% of people are the this
um project covers 30 days worth of
discharge medications and our goal is
obviously to cre increase continuity of
transfer treatment so that we reduce
that reincarceration rate um that
affects our Pharmacy line in addition to
that we have a a major discount on the
Pharmaceuticals we're using in the
treatment of opioid use disorder and so
we're trying to be mindful again that we
don't want to budget for more than we
need but we also are still asking for
the footnote that if the pharmaceutical
costs increase nationally that we're
prepared to come back before physical
and genc for additional Appropriations
okay because it it um appears in two
places I think um I would also add we
also have our 340b purchasing through
partnership with health and human
services in our state and we're trying
to continue to reduce the cost of the
hepatitis C Pharmaceuticals in HIV
Pharmaceuticals used in the institutions
that's a big cost is that those are
those were at one time almost 150,000
per person receiving those medications
and now they're uh I think 15,000 and I
I'll verify those numbers I don't want
to be wrong there representative Ms um
i' I'd like to use this as as a like a
jumping off point on uh maybe a broader
discussion of medical and Pharmacy and I
know you've got a page on that in your
um in your presentation um I guess my my
question is
um the where does the funding for that
come from I mean I'm looking through the
the the materials it it appeared to me
that most of it's coming from General
funds yes but um you you've also
mentioned that you have this you know
waiver through
Medicaid um it just started trying to
understand that's how much you know
that's a federal program so how much of
the federal government is how much of
how much is coming from the federal
government versus the state New
Hampshire yeah represent months most
99.9% of what we spend on immate
healthare comes from the general fund
the project I just referenced literally
kicked off February 15th of 2025 and so
part of our forecasting over the next
few years was in this line and hoping
that we would reduce it through that
work I don't have I won't be able to let
you know as we until we navigate um each
month thereafter on the federal portion
I will like to add um that under current
Medicaid rules if someone uh ends up in
an inpatient stay at a hospital during
incarceration uh we can remit for
Medicaid to retr cover that impatient
day so I say that because we've deferred
almost $2 million to be paid under
Medicaid for impatient stay during
incarceration for inmates in the absence
of that that $2 million would be paid
under the general fund
the process we've understood is the way
in which your stay at a hospital is
ordered is based on the provider who
literally writes in the order so for any
one of us if we're in the hospital a
provider orders in writing fundamentally
that I'm in here for an inpatient day or
they can order you in for an observation
stay if you in the hospital under an
observation stay and you're there for
seven days and you're an inmate that
can't be reimbursed under
Medicaid um how much have you how much
in Medicaid uh reimbursement under this
new waiver program have you assumed in
the budget for 26 and 27 I I'll get that
to you I don't have that right in front
of me today that we're forecasting and
and and I guess that you know will lead
to my final question which is you know
given that um the the budget in
Washington the proposed budget in
Washington has you know approximately
$800 billion dollar of Medicaid Cuts
included in it um you know it would be
good to know that to to understand you
know what the risk to the uh the state
budget's going to be if um some of those
cuts end up impacting this this program
thank you I think that's a very uh
thoughtful question we'll get we'll get
on that
all right so the last uh page that I
wanted to look at was
um which is Professional
Standards so what is that thank you
represent McGuire our division of
Professional Standards houses our uh New
Hampshire Department of Corrections
investigators uh as well as our prison
rape elimination act uh employees we
have to meet that Federal standard
annually and that it also includes our
agency auditor and a state
administrative rules writer and policy
writer so in order to comply with the
standards of New Hampshire RSA
106l uh which is the valid complaint
against a certified or certifiable law
enforcement officer uh a portion of
those investigators do under that
statute a valid law enforcement
investigation uh since the Inception of
that law in January 1 of 2020 three
we've learned uh we needed additional
resources so I recently reclassed a
position to add to that um the in
incarcerated population makes a lot of
allegations um and those allegations
have to be investigated according to
that law in addition to if those
allegations are criminal in nature we
have to have a solid partnership with
the attorney general's public Integrity
unit so that we make the right
notifications at the right time within
the right standards all balanced by
employees rights under the collective
bargaining agreement ment it's a very
complex but appropriate uh set of
standards and uh this division is the
primary resource there I also want to
then shift gears that inmates uh try to
bring in Contraband they engage in
assaults and all those other things and
this division does all of that
investigative work as well as criminal
charges referrals if somebody assaults
an officer assaults a staff member any
of those things this uh division make
sure that Justice is actually
effectuated in those cases uh we under
the switching gears prison rape
elimination act audit three sites a year
every every year in a three-year cycle
and if the department does not meet the
uh prison rape elimination act standards
we affect uh burn Jag dollars that would
come into the state in the form of
Federal grant dollars the department has
passed our Audits and so the positions
dedicated to that are to make sure we
continue to do so now are these um
mostly group two I mean it's sort of
what I would think of as a police
detective kind of that's a very fair
analogy yes there most of now 15 of them
are all certified uh New Hampshire
Department of Corrections law
enforcement great okay very good so I
else representative Evo they they
prepared a very thorough presentation
here and I just wondered in our
questioning if there were things that
you would like us to know from your
presentation I noticed in particular you
talked about the um the new prison oh
yes we we need to talk about that thank
you again we did not want to uh take you
through the same presentation we did the
last time as it's the same proposed
budget I did add additional Pages uh
just thinking you may have questions
about the proportion Min and so you'll
see those on
two uh we anticipated the question uh
which was answered on page three um
again page four and five I don't want to
take you through all of those but again
it's to help again follow up on that
presentation and give you more detail on
page 11 I do want to point out um
decisions made by the legislature to
fund uh additional specialty courts I
wanted you to go uh fully informed on
what a cost of one probation and prol
officer would look like and what those
lines um are included if you if you so
fund it we would ask that you add or ask
how many probation prol opers would be
necessary and put that complement in our
budget if through the legislative
budgeting process those specialty courts
are funded uh we don't we really want to
be a good partner but we don't want to
be where we were through the
implementation of drug courts so that's
on page 11 following that page and
hearing the um questions and I have
consulted with the is there a bill
number associated with that one my my
understanding is uh when I was here the
last time uh you had shared someone had
shared that judge Delker talked about
the young adult Court happening in
Manchester we do not currently have an
additional probation and parol officer
we have agreed to uh take some portion
of an existing officer to support three
to five people but that limits the
number of people they can have in that
um young adult
Court I I just don't we don't have the
additional resource so is it a bill I
don't think it's I haven't it was in the
in the judicial Grant presentation yeah
presentation there was some discussion
of it okay
just to give you the information you
need as you navigate any other agencies
ask that could affect the department
along the lines of if you put pull a
thread here other things it's just all
connected absolutely yeah Melissa can
you track that down if it's in somebody
else's budget yeah okay yes I can look
into that it was brought up by the
judicial branch okay very soon okay and
then on page 12 and 13 we try to uh give
you a nice brief one pager I did uh
listen to representative wer um talking
about this and he explained it very well
um but we wanted to make sure you had
those resources on page 12 and 11 so the
$10 million came out of hb2 as part of
the fy2 2425 budget um and we have a the
contracted partner who is DLR group is
uh well on time with that project in
looking at the physical ground and any
geologicals and um also doing what's
called programming and trying to
understand what we need what we have now
um how to think about uh how we put a
building on the physical ground in a way
to create efficiency we've talked about
technology so they've met with every
area of the department uh who is part of
the operation at the New Hampshire state
prison for men and we're going to have
some follow-up meetings to see how much
uh square feet they're forecasting right
now the $10 million will not get you to
bid speec documents it's to do do some
base ground work if you turn the page to
page uh 13 this $40 million intention
through
HB uh
2024 uh literally is to do that so that
we get the $10 million investment then
we get the $40 million investment which
is here are the blueprints and here's
what it will look like and here's where
the Mechanicals and the all of the
electricity and everything is I'm
working with the Department of Public
Works on that process they're putting
out what they refer to as an RFI I'm not
going to uh pretend to be an expert on
what that means for the Department of
Public Works I am much more familiar
with requests for proposals um but it's
to Garner interest from Engineers to let
them know that's what the eye is for
request for or information yeah uh to
Garner interest in this $40 million
project let uh um National firms know
this is where we're headed and the last
conversation I understand things change
is that we intended to put out a request
for proposal in the month of March I
have provided um narrative information
to include in that proposal and continue
to work with them on it um so I put the
what's included in the $40 million I
will tell you the $10 million and the
geological shows that we can build back
there um and so that's good news there
is water just like on any um landscape
remember we wasted two years on the
women's prison trying to find a location
that's correct sir and I'm delighted to
see bonding authorities so we don't have
to put it in the budget it put put in
the capital budget so that's we still
pay it though no it's it's less yes we
have to deal with an hp1 sure right and
I I have been uh speaking with the
treasurer to let her know where this
project is we did just have a
conversation this week so uh talked
about it not needing to be bonded right
now because of where we are in the
process we won't we won't likely end up
with a contract because of the request
for proposal process until after June of
2024 uh we first further theoretically
discussed whether we needed to bond all
40 million at once um and we have had
some suggestive conversation that they
could do 20 million in one fiscal year
and 20 million in the other and I will
defer all that type of expertise to the
accounting be 2027 before they even know
what's the proposal it's true sir
representative evil then representative
M um I think I know the answer to this
question but I looked at the capital
budget proposal from the governor and we
didn't there's no additional monies uh
for the new prison in the capital budget
and I didn't see anything of course in
the operate so so at this point um this
is all the money that you have this is
the money that uh is invested in
understanding what it would cost the
state of New Hampshire to replace the
New Hampshire state prison for men yes
we do have some capital budget
appropriation requests because we still
need to keep the infrastructure afloat
while we continue this work I I I can't
remember it's like12 million or sounds
that's quite a bit to just keep things
rolling refes Ms thank you Mr chair this
is a question for uh my more experienced
members of the committee here um if a it
where does The Debt Service get charged
does that that end up in the treasur bu
it's in the treasurer's budget yeah we
had her before but she's going to come
back at some point okay so it doesn't
hit the Department's budget no okay know
and yeah we're paying unh's debt in our
treasur budget anyways um the key thing
with this P new prison is to design it
like Berlin to be efficient with with uh
in the way number of officers needed for
per per
inmate unlike conquered presence that's
correct yeah okay yeah one key factor in
every convers ation I have had is we
have areas of our department that may be
asking for things but if we can't staff
a building then the building will never
work so we've also continued to share
with them what our current Staffing is
what our historical staffing has been um
and I'll give you a simple example
designing a control room in a prison
that requires two people and we have
never historically been able to put two
people and it is an automatic um recipe
for failure yeah okay so
continue and again so I I anticipated
you'd have more uh questions on the
formal line by line budget uh didn't
want to go through all of these Pages
again but wanted to just provide you the
same uh similar presentation resources
so if you have any uh questions from the
last time I didn't answer I can
certainly uh go through those or any
additional questions on the line let's
go to the hb2 things yeah I just Melissa
could you just get us the information on
the bonding if it's in the capital
budget just where it is just so we can
see the
bill just get us the bill that's what I
just want to see y I'll email it it's PB
2024 yep
thanks yes representative
Le so going back to the budget on page
501 dealing with employee development I
see that you're reducing that from 15 to
10 I was just curious
of the impact or why it's on page 501
and
502 yeah is that the training
line uh thank you representative leean
we we reduce that um to meet the target
it would mean $155,000 less in
um you're talking
personnel there you go okay um we just
moved them to different accounting units
where they made more sense for them to
be charged it's not really reducing the
support for that
division further question yes I'm
guessing these were vacant positions
right or
no no not necessarily I mean I'm not
sure looking at this but it's not
necessarily they were vacant they just
some of them went to the HR counting
unit and some of them went to um 7101
all right representative Lehman thanks
Mr chairman so I think we probably all
know that you are the greatest Grabber
of General funds of of all uh agencies
and government at least in state
government here and I appreciate uh you
holding the line I looked at the of
course the last page 507 the same number
of employees looks like you're knocking
things down again but of course my
concern uh that you do have that
authority to go to fiscal if you exceed
your expenses to ask for additional
funding you feel pretty confident that
you've got enough money here so you
don't have to come to fiscal very often
or representative lean I appreciate that
and I I think it would especially in the
health care side I think that's always a
challenge and I'll just give you a for
example I have a person uh we have an
inmate who just came in who is costing
us $20,000 a month uh in Pharmaceuticals
and so I'm looking at what their
sentence structure is I'm looking at
what their crimes are and trying to
decide if it's appropriate for medical
Parole in this instance uh the amount of
time they've been incarcerated and their
crime type I can't in good conscience
sign a medical parole and put the victim
of that person's crime through a medical
parole so I am making a conscious
decision balanced with what I just
stated that it's going to cost us
$20,000
Mon and again nice nice handout very
well put together as usual thanks thanks
Mr chairman thank you all right so um
should we look at the house bill too
briefly here there's looks like two
items or something I did uh put those on
page uh nine and 10 of my presentation
if it's easier um and cited the pages
from the the bill
the first footnote is again about
overtime and adds the piece we spoke
about last time and this time that if
the historical strategy uh didn't meet
the measure to fund overtime we would
come before fiscal and and then uh so on
to governor and councel the second item
is a cleanup item because uh through
legislative process we've added a
unclassified we took a classified Deputy
Ward and made it an unclassified Deputy
Warden and we have Deputy directors who
are unclassified so just fixing that
2187 and then are these in the
Commissioner's Office the first section
of the budget the different positions
are throughout different accounting
units depending on who they support so
for example if there's a deputy director
of rehabilit ative Services which there
is they're under that accounting unit as
a CL unclassified
employee and the deputy warden for
example will be under the New Hampshire
State prison's accounting unit and
you'll see a change in number of
classified and unclassified it'll go
from one to one
I the uh other request was around the
industry's inventory account talking
about those permanent positions and uh
fixing uh what we learned is they are
being charged to that fund but the
statutes not allow aligned to that and
we we identified that as an area in
which we needed to bring forward for
yes I see we don't want the general fund
to pay for those positions
okay any other questions about
this all right represent wer I'm
impressed at how well prepared you are
thank you very much thank you sir I
appreciate
that thank you sir you so we can either
we can either talk to the parole board
early or we can wait 15 minutes what do
you I think I see him here so
here so is that going to break our uh
procedures no we'll be okay all right I
me there there're a sub agency of
Department of Correction so I think they
there so we're good they're
administratively attached okay and that
might give us a little more time for
military right so all right thank you
very much
commissioner all right parl board which
is on I think it's just the next page
thank you this almost thicker than the
other
you Mr
mck good morning chair members of the
committee uh my name is Roger Phillips
and I'm a chairperson of the Adult
Parole
Board excuse
me the um um in order to meet the
governor's Target budget
goal uh we had
to U in order to accomplish that we had
to eliminate a a staff member um um and
so we're here today asking for
reinstatement of that as you're probably
aware where and I I understand the the
problems associated with with the
revenue side of the budget that the
state of New Hampshire is is facing uh
on the other hand it can affect a a
small Department like ours more
drastically than it will a larger U
department so are you saying one of the
four is is unfunded is that
and although
in we had in November asked for that to
be included it it didn't make the
trailer budget either um is this a
vacant position or it is not a vacant
position it is is one that is filled now
and one obviously that we rely upon um
the challenges of parole and parole
revation are no different now than they
were a few years ago um the the there
are some uh exciting things in in the
sense that in
communities people now have an
opportunity to go into a a sober house
when they're uh when they're paring from
a
um uh the state's prison and um I do not
know what will happen of
course on the federal side in the event
that the that Medicaid is changed
because uh those who those inmates who
are released and on parole uh more often
than not are on Medicare in order to get
the treatment that they need both
medical and for substance
abuse would you like to with me today is
Jay Mackey who's director of
operations uh who who could address
other we tried to put together in our
our our packet what
um information concerning our our our
function and and what we do and how
we're hopefully moving uh to the stage
of of evidence-based decision making um
and the federal government through the
the department of of Corrections is and
we are now on the list uh as a state as
the third state to receive it this this
coming year U but as a result board
members are going to have to be be
trained in that U and the I idea of
evidence-based decision making is that
all members are looking at the same
materials the eight or so domains that
are that I needed and that any board
member would come to the same decision
uh face with with this information so
hopefully the my bias in whatever
fashion I'm I don't think I have doesn't
raise its its ugly head as we we do that
but it it does require uh us to at least
I I would hope that we had an audit uh
up you know in in
2019 uh I I came on the board that year
uh as a
member and
um there have been substantial changes
made in the in the parole office and I I
think we more efficient we now are at
least we're working with laptop
computers and have digital packets as
opposed to the paper that we had years
ago um but the the the main reason we
want to to do it on the the the next to
last page of of of the packet in
indicates activity in
2004 20 24 I wanted want you to
understand that that's only a 9month
version the that isn't up to date just
for your information the the governor
did put in your $10,000 for out of state
travel
oh in in your budget all right so yeah
so that's already
okay yes represent thank you m thank you
Mr chair and thank you for coming in um
the one position that is um proposed to
be eliminated which one is that I'm
looking at your your organization chart
on page
three um I I can answer that so I had
submitted two organizational charts okay
um one with and one without that
position that so the first one is the
one with the position position and it is
the secretary
2 okay position that position as we said
is currently filled it is mainly
responsible for the scheduling of peole
hearings as well as um vetting all the
plans when when a parole Le is when an
inmate is approved for parole we then
have to send out their uh housing plan
to the doc Field Services to be
investigated prior to their
release that position that one of her
main functions is is vetting all those
housing plans sending them out to field
in we we currently have six staff
including myself in the office five
full-time one
part-time and we originally looked at
cutting the part-time position but that
wouldn't bring us down we could get
under the target number but we would
have no money except for salaries so we
had to choose a full-time position
to do and that basically Cuts about 17%
of our
Workforce as you know chair Philip said
it it's where much smaller
agency now did you get more you got more
there that also board members stiens oh
I see yes their annual stiens
gotcha yeah which we changed I guess
last time a little bit yeah okay roughly
how much of that is is the
board uh 40 70
130 oh so it's almost all of the board
almost all of it yeah oh
okay the chairperson gets
40,000 they I mean the vice chairperson
gets 40,000 the other three board
members get 30,000 annually gotcha okay
and how often does the board
meet um most every Tuesday is a
revocation day and most every Thursday
uh are parole days and we also have an
administrated meeting on the fourth
Friday of every
month but it's not the hearing days
there's a lot of homework the
preparation that's right yeah yeah I
before yes 90 to 100 Pages for plle
when I started the cardboard cart would
be delivered to the front porch of my
house of of just paper yeah and would'
have to go through that over the the
weekend to get ready for the either the
V you can ask all right representative
evil on your chart which is the position
that you cut it would be the page before
that the uh secretary 2
that
gotcha and then in the very last page of
your presentation if that was
reinstated that is what she would is
expected to
um her with her salary and benefits over
fiscal year 26 and 27
okay in other words that is the amount
we're
seeking so
just if you lose that person
does that mean that the number of folks
that might be eligible for parole it
just slows down the whole process or if
you have people that
are supposed to come off or you know
they're being they're they're having a
hearing to see if they need to go back
to jail I mean does the whole Pro does
the whole process really slow down
because you don't have the support staff
it it will slow down uh recently we
we've actually been running without a
sta one staff member office over the
last few months because of multiple
issues that actual the secretary 2 went
out on medical leave for about a month
and right when she came back I went out
I'm just returning from back surgery
myself um when we have people go on
vacations and miss some time we're able
to to figure it out but if we lose that
staff member it you know um it will slow
our process down a bit I mean I guess
I'm just thinking about it in terms of
administrative administration of justice
and also if if you look at the cost of
incarceration if you're slowing down the
number of people that can go on
parole it keeps those numbers up if they
stay incarcerated longer then they might
otherwise have to because they weren't
able to you weren't able to get through
the parole process as quickly as we do
our very best to make certain right I'm
sure you do a PE hearing before I'm not
slamming you I'm just trying to to to
say that without adequate Staffing a lot
of that gums up yes well that's right
especially in a small office where if
someone is ill or out and these folks
are trying to do more than just one
function they they'll step into the
shoes of someone else but without that
extra person that's going to be very
difficult well and conversely if
somebody shouldn't be on parole anymore
you want to get them off the streets
if they should be
welcome represent
W so when you went from that box full of
paperwork that somebody had to make
copies of to computer how much did that
save in office time and and preparation
not only for what not it didn't save
your preparation but the office should
have been saved a lot of preparation
time from boxing it up copying it all
and make sure everybody got
delivered that's true but there's also
one other thing that's happened the the
parole office for years has relied on
paper Y and all of this has to be
scanned in now so we have records if we
lose a staff member like that how are we
ever going to
get up to date and scanning the things
that that that should be done um and
then it will they'll be scanned and into
file hold and that was my hope is that
we would be able to start because we
still have paper file cabinets these
things have to be scanned and and put in
and um I'm really concerned about that
and I think it's essential that we have
that person available so that could be
accomplished yeah the scanning is almost
as as timely as as the cop paper copying
are your records duplicated at the
Department of Corrections no no well
there we have a crossover between the
two because Department of Corrections do
supervise the PRS of the community but
what we have right now which is still an
archaic system is we have the green file
that we produce when somebody goes up
for a parole hearing they then when once
they're approved for parole and they go
out into parole that green file gets
sent to that district office for that
parole officer and then if and then any
supervision stuff that needs to be done
is put in that file and if they come
back to the prison for revocation that
green file gets sent back to us it's a
whole back and forth thing so yes some
of the files but
we our parole board files are separate
from the doc files I see but but all
this green file thing is paper still yes
I see which is we we've been talking
about switching it over kind of trying
to get into the process of switching it
all over all our interstate land people
that are now Ono in other states have
started to be scanned into the the
database M okay all right other
questions no yes represent a m thank you
if I'm I'm I'm looking at your um your
your cover letter in your in your packet
um and it it it it looks like this
additional staff person was a direct
result of the LBA audit yes and the
recommendations included in there um so
I'm assuming that and I think you say
this in your in your letter but if that
position is
eliminated you would run the risk of uh
kind of running a running a foul of uh
the audit the audit results of of of the
recommendations that's right we're
finally getting to that point where we
can be more efficient and do things well
and that y okay I think it would have an
adverse impact okay thank you
so for me just looking at your or chart
if I were eliminating one position it
would be the
supervisor right because you have two
chiefs for four Indians here right and
so couldn't the director supervise
everybody
else that that was the position that was
created by the audit um the supervisor
position the that person is currently in
charge of running all the revocation
hearings M if we were to lose that that
position with all of the so we chose to
eliminate the position that had the the
lowest labor grade with the least amount
of responsibilities so the office could
still function if we are unable to get
it back it would it would be taking on a
lot less if we remove the
supervisor and now we have to take those
high level duties to dispers amongst
myself or other people at a lower level
it it it'll so saying that person is
really more in parallel with you right
you're doing the parole hearings and
they're doing the rication hearings
she's doing the rication hearings the
parole hearings are done by the case
manager y I'm overseeing everything okay
but I'm also responsible for you know
getting all the inmates back that are in
uh revocations tracking them when
they're out of state and coming back as
well as obviously so that person is not
really supervising all other she does
she does she does some of the the
all right well maybe we have to talk
about that okay thank you other
questions no don't see any thank you
very much thank you all right so is
the since we're going what take a
break five minutes
okay we we have almost 10 minutes nine
minutes
okay
e
206 good morning Mr chair and committee
members for the record I'm Major General
David mtis uh Adent general for New
Hampshire National Guard commissioner
Department of military Affairs and
veteran services and I'm joining here
today with the deputy ad General Miss
Nicole Bixler how are you so broadly
speaking I just want to cover the
mission statement broad overview of
Department of military Affairs and vet
services we'll go into some details and
then I'll defer to you all for any
questions you may have on specifics so
first and foremost Department of
military Affairs and veteran services
has a dual Mission primary mission is to
support the women men and women soldiers
Airmen and federal civilians within the
New Hampshire National Guard that number
over 3,000 strong our secondary mission
is to support the over 990,000 veterans
in the state of New
Hampshire in our veteran service
portfolio that includes the Veteran
Cemetery Division of Community Based
military programs and the division of
veteran services so those are our two
broad mission statements to support the
men and women in uniform that include
over 3,000 service members and federal
civilians and the 90,000 V in the state
of New
Hampshire when you want to take a look
at our agency budget over 80% of our
state operating but over 80% of our
operating budget is federal funds 177%
of our federal of our state operating
budget is General funds um we were able
to meet the governor's targeted budget
request that came at a a slight cost to
our military Affairs our National Guard
portfolio which affected sort of our
Armory portfolio which we have over 20
armories throughout the state and our
state active duty
account we also took limited hits to our
veteran service portfolio which affected
our Division of Community Based military
programs and our Veteran
Cemetery within the governor's trailer
build language there was no impact to
the Department of military Affairs and
veteran services
current vacancies we currently have 19
vacancies within the department of
military Affairs and veteran
services 18 of those positions are
either 100% federally reimbursed or
generally have a 75 Federal 25% general
fund cost
share we only have one
part-time vacant position that is
generally funded and it was an
administrative
position when you look at the challenges
face in this budget we can live within
our means in the T Governor's targeted
request um we are not requesting any
additional funds but I would offer to
you that the challenge in this fiscal
environment also is at the federal level
for example through executive voters
we're dealing with an 8% reduction in
the federal civilian Workforce that
affects our federal civilians which
support the men and women in the
Hampshire National Guard uh today or
next Monday we will start the deferral
uh the layoff of uh people have signed
up for deferred um res ation and we're
currently awaiting additional guidance
on what to do with our federal civilian
probationary employees who have been
employed for less than a year so within
our Workforce there's a lot of turmoil
on con a lot of turmoil on friction and
so of those 19 vacancies of which 18 or
100% generally funded or 75 25 uh
federal state cost year we really need
those positions they all fund and
support the men and women in the
Hampshire National Guard none of them
are currently in line with our veteran
service
portfolio subject your questions that's
all I have all
right um let's uh let's look at this
page 206 um so it looks like you're
spending
um you actually spent in turn in
2024 one and a. half million of General
funds but um you you want that to go up
by
about uh looks like 800,000
that so were there so is that the 19 the
general fund part of those 19 positions
or is it something
else can
uh vacant position it uh sir was mostly
vacant
positions okay so are they still vacant
or
not yes okay but you want to hire them
is that the idea there's airing yes the
uh there's a state hiring freeze we've
put in for a few positions to get
waivers for that are 100% federally
reimburse right now and in the process
if there's a 75 25 Federal uh federal
government 25% General funded State cost
year we are looking to hire those
positions as well I'm sorry yeah I'm I
was looking at this um veteran services
now the whole thing I'm sorry I had the
the number so it's $2 million more of
General funds right
yeah page page 206 yeah at the bottom
yeah yeah yeah sorry oh the 40 million
to 42 to
42 right so in 2004 you spent 5 A5
million of General funds I got it right
and now we're going to 7 point something
right so it's it's more or less 2
million
more um that was our inability to
execute construction contracts um or
service agreements that had a federal
state cost share
so we sort of dropped General funds
because we couldn't execute the federal
dollars associated with it okay so is
and and the and the federal funds is
going up hugely right I mean it's it's
um but you saying this is up in the air
right the 16 million kind of
number no uh sir generally speaking we
significantly underere executed because
our inability to procure our contract
services that had a federal match oh I
see
okay but you think that's going to
change
yes okay well maybe we can get to sort
of exactly where in the budget those
things are yep so essentially sir you
want additional clarification on that
sort of that line on page 206 well yeah
I mean this is the the bottom line right
so so yeah where
is where is the extra $2 million of
General funds being
spent so there was a
uh of the $2 million I think it goes
there's like three or four different
places I think one was the state
vacancies the state position vacancies
that had a state cost share that's part
of it number two is our inability to
execute State contracts with the federal
match and number three was um sometimes
during continuing resolutions when we
receive the federal funds too late
it exasperates our problem with
executing those like for example an
Armory a read the center the 18 to 20
that we have throughout the state is a
50/50 federal state cost share so when
under continuing resolution sometimes we
get the federal dollars late and it
exasperates our compounds our problem of
how we can execute those funds so we had
uh one or two substandard years of which
we uh had to transfer the federal
dollars into other accounts uh for it to
be spent and therefore we underere
executed are General funds gotcha so why
don't we go through the pages and we'll
we'll kind of highlight places where
General funds are used because that's
our our main concern here all
right so let's see start with one page
[Music]
okay
um Administration and armories
okay so here's an example right
so um general fund going up uh by a
third right from 1.5 to
two
million well 20 so are you going to
spend in 2025 2.1 in this
area page 179 right yeah well 179 goes
are so it looks like there were
vacancies
probably
yep V
contracts
and and uh so was vacant positions are
inability to execute contracts and it
was the Challenger the difference in
utility bills yes utility bills rents
are going up and and heat electricity
Etc right so we uh we have over 66
buildings in in the Army National Guard
and 44 buildings in the International
Guard so we have over 100 buildings so
we pay a fair amount of uh we have a lot
of real
estate but but you only was was 2024 a
very light year for electricity cuz you
only spent the 1.544 for well the
71,000 I'm I'm looking on page
179 line
right so that 71,000 is going up to 120
a
year and your rents are going from 277
to
400 so I'm going to defer to Judy Chang
our Chief Financial Officer um that's a
good idea
yeah use that microphone right on the
corner
there W okay so basically for the
utility things is um we're trying to use
the federal resource to to you know to
save the the general funds and and the
plus we have a the very warm year in the
24 so that's why the utility funds is
it's much lower than we anticipate so we
did a budget around the 220,000 but we
only spend 71,000 I see what you're
saying yeah okay and
rents uh the rent is ready for the city
of conquer for the land we have the the
airport land and so basically the
increase depend on the the index every
year so the index keep changing so for
the last three years the index still the
same roughly but when we do the budget
we anticipate the index with increase
that's the reason and current
expense um current expense that think
the current expense is normally we move
that money into because when the DS
changed for the snow point and for the
trash they want the coding to 103
instead the in know traditional Rec
coding in the class 20 that's why we
move the money M
okay all right and also your it costs
are going up it looks like yeah the it
cost is ready for the
doit uh are you talking about the class
27 right yes so it's really doit U
wherever they budget yes they charge us
for the cost allocation then we just do
as they charge us
okay all right so that was one
page um let's see page
181 yes representative sorry Mr chair on
before we leave um uh 180 uh page 180
the contracts for operational services
that line went up quite a bit what what
is that
so we have the one incident when the
people hit our
gate and uh um do you want to talk about
that the gate on the pamur gate yeah so
we had an incident where uh I can't
remember who it was um had a medical
emergency and hit our security gate at
one of our entrances to our reservation
and we had to Contract Services to fix
the retaining wall the the metal fencing
and the gate itself that opens and
closes automatically with an access card
reader so I think that was a significant
onetime hit and we had to pay for just
generally that that line and operational
Services that's it's that kind of thing
where you need to hire somebody to come
in and do some work okay thank you but
you won't necessarily ongoing need quite
so much right um we also has the roof
issues our building is very old you want
to talk about the so we can use this one
to fix
coding as 100% General from coding
buildings okay to fix yeah most of our
building is either 100% federal or 5050
75 25 but we still have a few of the
building coding as 100% General funds
and we want to fix the roof with the
edge pack and the boil all those things
that's the purpose is that what so
you're saying some of the buildings are
General funds and some of them very few
we only have a one or two buildings
gotcha I see
okay all right um then on page
that yes so 182 is 75% Federal sheare
and 25% State sheare for the Army
National Guard supporting but where's
some of these 18 positions vacant yes so
some of that is the V positions um
because that's a 7525 year uh at that
time in 2024 we have a vacant positions
but we slowly uh fill all those position
already so for the sheet with uh the
general talking about the 19 weing
positions we don't have in the account
yet so pretty much we fill all those
positions now in this case the
electricity bill is not going up so much
one so for this utility bill we hope so
one thing that we're trying to meet the
governor's Target so we trying to manage
the whole Department's budgets and uh
that's the one reason so we're trying to
do more efficiencies with our new
buildings especially when we looking for
the capital budget to do the all the
renovation stuff so hopefully and the
Energy Efficiency will helping us uh
second things is uh we want that budget
as close as we participate because Das
changed the rule so in case if we have
the warm weather and we didn't spend the
utility money uh it can be Moval for any
other
use gotcha all right we're going to move
4 Mr chair usually we're just a pass
through so what happens is the committee
gives us the money we pass it through to
Civil Air Patrol and if there's a cut
based upon the governor's efficiency
budget we just sort of cut what's passed
through we don't we don't we don't take
any of it it's just it's what the state
gives to them when we're just the what
is civil air patrol it's there's a
corner building near our state Military
Reservation I think it's regional Drive
and Airport Road and it's the youth
based crew uh program like high school
kids who show up for like a day or twice
a month and they wear like an Air Force
uniform they learn about avionics and
airplanes and they fly so there's like
retired military who are their
instructors and it's just it's to get
them into like aviation industry it's
almost like a junior RC program navc
Cadets very similar it just happens to
be house on the corner next to our
reservation
gotcha yeah you like it yeah so the
governor trimmed it a bit it looks like
yeah well usually what we'll do is we'll
incorporate those budget
reductions into their account and we'll
notify them that Hey listen based upon
like you know the current fiscal
climate because all we do is we're just
a pass through gotcha okay
um uh so this one is one I remember from
last time page 199 enlistment
incentive so we really increased that I
time well it was General funds right
yeah so so uh sir I would offer to you
that the biggest um the biggest
challenge for the United States military
is not China or Russia it's our ability
to fill our formations of an all
volunteer force and we struggle at our
New Hampshire International Guard um
location location and new KC 46 refueler
we are 100% fully man I'm in the Army
National Guard with about 1760 positions
we're running actually like a 10%
unemployment rate um that's actually
fairly significant for our ability to
dur our number one Mission which is the
fight America's Wars and so anything
that we can do to help the accessions of
bringing in new recruits or the
retention of those service members into
so you know there's a couple of best
practices that we've seen from other
states so we now offer like say dot a
$1,000 referral program so if you're
you're an listed member of retiree in
the New Hampshire National Guard you
refer someone to join us you get
$1,000 this year we expanded it to um do
a uh a state retention bonus so in the
event the feds do not offer you a say
six-year
$20,000 reenlistment bonus um we've
developed through the legislature a
state retention bonus of really it's
nominal it's like
$4,000 and so we're trying to apply some
resources to ensure that we can recruit
and then retain a quality volunteer
Force that's the why how many new um
people are recruited every
year it's a revolving door yeah so
generally speaking I'll just talk about
the Army
guard uh 15% turnover rate so every year
we need to get 200 soldiers
in every year we ATT Tri 2 to 210 so the
challenge is because an enlistment
contract can vary between 3 to six years
so that we're planting this current
generation yes they want to serve but a
lman contract is typically what we call
a 3x5 three years of active service in
the National Guard week and a month and
five years independent ready Reserve
because surface members will come in I
served got my tuition waiver did my call
serve my country I'm good and so the
challenge is um trying to keep service
members in after that first enlistment
because there's no more 20-year
retirement uh the federal government get
rid of it so now we're at
401K so you join now as a junior and
listed um you don't wait for that 20e
retirement that you're going to get at
age either 42 or 60 depending if you're
a full-time part-time um it's a 401k so
there's really no Financial incentive
for service members when they to stay a
particularly length of time because life
takes over they get a promotion to the
civilian job they get their education
they have a house a kid and next thing
you know um life gets busy and and so
we're having it recruiting is isn't as
big of an issue as it currently is right
now with
retention and so we're trying to figure
out different ways of retention and so
um and so an example we partnered with
the university system of New Hampshire
and the community college system of New
Hampshire so if you reinlist um after
your first six years
that free tuition waiver to the
university is transferable to your
spouse because we're trying to retain
that family member as well those are the
creative things we've been trying to do
now you just said you're recruiting 200
a year but you also said there are 3,000
National Guard and 15% turnover so that'
be more like 450 a year right that's
just Army on the International Guard we
about 1100 and so it's the same it's
almost by 10% their National Guard has
less turnover um they're about 1100
strong we typically have to assess about
120 on the Army it's technically 250 but
I say 200 because that's what we call
non- prior Services sessions then you
have officer commissioning then you have
Interstate transfers so generally
speaking we'll bring in about 250 new
soldiers or service members in the Army
guard of a force about 1757
1760 oh okay
so what you're saying is they're in two
groups ye yes regular National Guard and
Air National Guard that the Army the
Army Army's Army about 250 air about 110
Army okay I
see
gotcha s about five years ago um they
thought they were going to save money
the federal government and uh it went to
uh 401K we called a blended return
BRS you get you get well that's the
whole point was you now get something
for any term Of
Enlistment versus the 20% who would do
20 years so now everyone gets something
but people don't have the incentive for
the 20
right
[Music]
right okay but but this this this small
amount of money here this
$100,000 you
can't you can't divide it very much I
mean not everybody is getting this or oh
no so you know generally speaking I
believe we do about 40 referrals a
year um and then we just started the
state retention program it passed the
legislature last uh year so this is our
first year the policy just went out so
we're in the sort of initial stages of
sort of testing demand signal like hey
what's out
there okay all right thank you so page
uh let's see
cemetery okay 202
202 yeah so there's a large increase in
general funds
here right so it it in 2024 was only six
$116,000 that's going up to 250 260 per
come so that one is because we have the
so thatc is 100% general fund but
however we received the if the veteran
barrier in our Veteran Cemetery we
receive from the the VA with the vrine
um the revenue and also uh if you see
the uh the agency income is when we bury
you the sports and the dependence that's
we collect the money from the family so
normally is so in this case uh on the
federal funding last year they Chang the
Perfection rates so right now is so
every October 1st they change they
increased the rat so last year the rates
increased tremendous I think it's a
700 80 I'm not really sure I can go
double check but around that thing so
when we have that and we're trying to
decrease general funds to to basically
use our you know the revenue to cover
the general fund so I think of it like
this uh the federal government gives us
a plot allowance for every veteran we
bury at the cemetery
about two three years ago a federal law
change where now a national a reservice
or National Guards person um who hasn't
been activated on what we call Title 10
like a deployment overseas or Southern
border um is now eligible for burial in
the Veteran Cemetery so that's a cost we
eat um to giving them a dignified final
resting ground based upon a change in a
I believe a federal
policy so I mean what we have we're
trying to cover the the that other cost
that was going to increase over time I
think we've had over 200 uh about 50
burials of those Guardsmen and reservist
and we have another 150 or 200 on the
books for like sort of a that's where
they're going to get
buried that and when we budget the
federal uh funds and the ageny income
again when we do the budget we have to
figure out how many barrier we were
going to have and that's a hot
projection for the barrier rate so that
probably you see the little bit
different between 24 and 25 what's the
family
cost is it
150 per person 150 150 per person versus
probably couple 3,000 for right I see
every the paper lists them all is 60 70
every month y yeah is that right so so I
just I guess the main thing here is the
expenses went up
right so um you must have had a vacancy
in 2024 maybe of the nine people not
it so yeah okay so this kind a little
bit difference so if our business
supervisor will know as well so when we
do the budgets you know you have the
like a clean up fiscal years 24 then
clean up the fiscal year 25 so in this
account
because that revenue is brought forward
so it's hard to you know to match the
systems as we can provide the actual
figure so instead so they the system
only give us the total but we want to
show the how much we receive funds how
much we receive the agency income that's
why the general fund you look like a g
fund is very little but actually is not
it just the system in the buy it just
doesn't reflect exactly so so the
general the general fund is what's left
when you subtract the other two from the
okay so I can get back to you on that
one the barrier for the family
150 you do you know when that was set um
that was set right in the beginning of
the cemetery open and uh it never
know um
normally the VAC CER the vaction CER
would do the annalysis across the
countries and if he decide change I
think we have to go to Governors and
physical to get approval and they had to
get the rule
change toen
all so we're looking into it valid valid
point we get we got to do some research
on that and ask our secetary
director yep okay because essentially
your question is um what is the current
rate for a family member of the Veteran
Cemetery when did it come into effect
and is it time to take a relook and see
what the the proposed cost should be if
Hampshire yeah I think it's 25 to be
honest with you I think we just
celebrated last year s 25 yeah we're
we're taking a serious look at fees
because there's some that were set 50
years ago and haven't changed you know
so like some of these
employes Bingo sir and so you know we're
trying to take a look at a sort of the
our veteran service portfol is 100%
generally funded so we have about 25
positions when you look at the the
cemetery the veteran service officers
and the division Community Based
military programs so we're taking a look
internally is as a veteran population
ages do we need as many veteran service
officers and as we double triple
quadruple because we're doing another
Federal expansion of the cemetery this
year do we need to put those resources
over to the cemetery because you right
now we've been getting by with
volunteers we have a lot of volunteer
associations who do the gardening up
there and a lot of the sort of uh
Aesthetics um yeah we're it's they're
there I believe it's the exact price
regardless of uh was it
cremation uh or barrial or burial or
like the box in the the not ears the
columbarium versus in the ground so I I
believe it's the same price and back to
just all right you'll find that out so
we're running out of time but I wanted
to ask about on page 20
204 um there's a big increase in general
funds in this area of veteran services
Mental Health social
that um you're talking about the
increase from fiscal 24 465,000 to
500 no the the next group the next thing
on the page oh this one contract for
program
Services right in 2024 was only
204 and now you're spending 650 is do
I'm going to try I think I know what it
is so I I believe the legislature one by
Animo specifically provided us a million
dollar to division Comm commity based
military programs to execute specific
programs like an ask the question
campaign in the contracts have finally
like they've come to fruition like we
got the money last bium and we're now
executing the contracts so that's why I
think you see the increase from you know
because the legislature gave us the
money to execute these contracts on
behalf of our veteran population am I
right right so in the addition
125,000 if you look at the fiscal is 25
that's is the Sy system the DHHS created
and we were going to pay as our share by
using the systems it's called the roof
referral um but because the contract
didn't get approved in time um for the
DHHS contract that's why we didn't
process we kind L that 125,000 24 but
for so you so there's like three or four
things that the legislature had us
chartered us to do is go get after
veteran homelessness um and there's
another program called ask the
question generally speaking there's
990,000 veterans in the state of New
Hampshire only a third of them receive
Care at the the Manchester VA or the
White River Junction VA so 60,000
veterans go to their primary care
provider so the program was initiated
about a a decade ago and we we're
putting teeth into it and continuing it
so it's you're a veteran you go to
primary care provider and that provider
should say have you
served and then they can get after
there's any mental health or substance
misuse issues to identify that veteran
with the appropriate resources so one of
our signature programs is called asked
the question campaign that's and then we
do a few other things like a veteran
friendly Business program to get hiring
a veterans with Employment Security in
the state of New Hampshire for employees
because we have such a state low uh
State unemployment rate so it's just
different contracted programs that we
try to get after for serving
veterans okay but some of these are
brand new right I
mean yes CU sir I believe the last
legislature mandated us with those three
positions right um that gave us three
positions and I think a million dollars
to get after like veteran
homelessness uh mental health and those
are another one
I don't see any position anyways last
last time I went to the VA they wanted
to make a big deal we exposed to agent
orange I was in an airplane where it was
being sprayed and and you know it was
supposed to be a line like this where
all the sprays going back but then we
come to a hill this plane next to us
goes up over the hill and we're down
here and we're get sprayed and the
windows are open in the airplane why do
you open the windows so they won't break
when the bullets hit them
yeah to it
so the other thing I'd say real quick
too is um this division of community-
based military programs has grown so in
2019 when the governor signed the
executive order and the legislature
codified into law that changes from
agent General's Department to military
Affairs and veteran services it was two
positions that came over from Health and
Human
Services I believe it was the last
legislature you all gave us a mandate to
hire three more State positions we went
from two to five and now this year we're
in the process of transferring a a one
more State position from education to us
which is called a state approval
Authority it's a person that just
certifies higher education is like meets
like GI B criteria so we keep
consolidating growing this I shouldn't
say growing but like we've been mandated
to like consolidate all these resources
in this one
division our division of veteran
services and cemeteries generally
haven't changed at all it's like 9 10
employees for each of one of these
portfolios this this one we've
Consolidated other resources and that's
why sometimes I think you see broader
fluctuations in budget right I'll let
represent months have the last question
but we thank you and I just wanted to
follow up on your questions about U the
contracts for program Services because
one of the things that I noticed is that
there was an overall increase in in
contracts for program Services of about
$2.2
million um I think from FY 24 to
25 um and it sounds like a million of
that may be what you what you just
explained the the the state government
giving you the authorization to move
forward with those programs do you have
any idea what the rest of the number
money is for what what what what's
driving that so I just want to uh make
sure I understand the question yet so
are you talking about the general fund
the difference from fiscal years 24 the
$2 million difference no I'm talk I'm
talking about overall spending not to
it's the expenses I'm not worried about
the funding um when I when I looked at
contracts for program services for the
entire
department it looked like there was a
$2.2 million increase from 24 to 25 and
then that carried forward to 26 right so
I'm trying trying to understand you know
what the what that money was for so do
that's for the 100% fed Z positions and
the security guard
oh good point so
um is what did it increase or change
increase we increase the security ta
security so so I believe what you're
referring to is um the we the security
contract at both our like New Hampshire
National Guard base at PE is a private
contract Security Forces like our
military personnel do not secure the
international Nation Guard base and that
contract is about 1.1 to $1.3 million a
year yeah so basically we have the um B
of Secura they do one is in the Army
National Guard one's at the P Air
National Guard so those is 100% Federal
funding and uh when several things years
the last years because we have a
difficulty with the receive the full
Federal funding so we change amend the
contracts to decrease now so now we
anticipate that the 100% federal funds
will ful refund to us so that's why we
increase uh the budget just make sure we
right sorry uh you had you had mentioned
up front and um that one of the the
biggest challenges that um we face is uh
the the the potential of federal of cuts
at the federal level um and I see that
you know in the news that there's talk
of a of the the defense department
cutting its budget by $50 billion every
year going forward um do you have any
sense yet as to what that would do to to
funding sir not yet what we do know is
um
we're losing people so we have U like I
I jokingly tell people we have five HR
departments full-time Army Air uh
National Guard full-time Air National
Guard then we we call this program
called the title 32 dual status
technician Army and air so you can be a
gs12 and a federal employee and you're
in the garden a week and a month but so
it's like it's a so we have and then we
have just Federal
civilians the initial proposal for an 8%
budget reduction in Personnel is the one
we're worried about the most and we
haven't seen other cuts to potential
programs in the future so right now for
us this sort of close Target is what is
going to be the reduction on our federal
Workforce and we know uh supposed to be
today but I have to do Monday because
some people on like vacation is uh
people who uh does an email that went
Elon Musk the fork in the road email
people took that and so we get no
backfill for those positions
and then what's going to happen with
probationary employees so generally with
this federal government your first year
is probationary they want to cut all
those positions so
so the initial concern for us that we
actually know about is what will be the
reduction in our federal Workforce we
don't know what other programs in the
future will be cut so wouldn't wouldn't
it simply be instead of 3,000 soldiers
you'll have 2700 or you know some
smaller
that's coming um right now it's the
several hundred Federal civilians that
we have I see who stays to support the
men and women in uniform right so when
you balance a state employees and
federal
civilians uh and you don't see the cost
of those federal payroll that's a SE
distinct thing so we get like $200
million a year to fund the military
personnel and our federal civilians um
that's just another sort of ancillary uh
but when you when you talk about um you
know reductions in in in staff I mean
are you talking about the 129 or so
people that you have these are other yes
okay so it's a 3,000 other people we
have so we have like 2,800 uniform
Personnel yeah and another 200 or so
Federal civilians then 129 State
civilians that's why we like five HR
departments oh because these These are
people that are on the state payroll
these are just state employees I got you
okay all right thank you very much
general for coming thanks sir and we'll
be back at 1:15 with the division of
resources the deputy the Warr Warren War
he just retired turned 6 had his first
grand kids and
Perry they didn't like to Army people so
it's Army and Air
care
e
I well I think some people got an email
from me at about 5:30 this
morning yeah so
anyways all right is it time
here yes it is 115
welcome hello good afternoon
yes um Sarah Stewart commissioner of the
Department of Natural and cultural res
resources I put together a few remarks
um if you'd be so kind um because the
last time we met we were still reviewing
a previous budget uh draft and um and
now we have some more information for
you so just for the people here we're on
page
602 to look at the the bottom line but
603 yeah thank you so DNC I
am
um yeah well so um so this Governor's
budget um re Governor aat budget reduces
the general fund overall um by
3.79% and within that you will see our
agency made an 11% reduction to our
general funds we we have gone from a
general fund total of
11,27 th000 plus change in fiscal year
9,955 th000 in fiscal year 2026 and
9,951 in fiscal year
27 thank you that's well I I'll point
out that this number is what you spent
in
2024 right so it's it's not what was
budgeted but it's what was spent so it's
I'll have more or less the same level I
have Chris Marino with me whenever we
talk numbers and he will look at that um
so the entire budget for dncr for fiscal
year 26 and 27 is about 65 million with
a vast majority of our funding coming
through Revenue the remaining General
funds after our 11% reduction is
critical to maintain the federal match
money available to provide important
services to our constituents for
instance we are preserving the general
fund allocation to the division of
historical resources to maintain the
review and compliance program in section
106 the loss of this program would stop
all state and federal project permitting
that would not be good we are reducing
the general fund allocation to the Arts
by an additional 110,000 in Grants from
the initial 300,000 we submitted during
the agency phase for 26 and 500,000 for
fiscal year 27 making the total amount
cut to equal 410,000 in fiscal year 26
and 600
0,000 for fiscal year 27 additionally we
are unfund a vacant General funded
position cutting another
80,000 plus in fiscal year 26 and 85,000
Plus in 27 and with a staff of only
seven in this division losing one
full-time employee creates a workload
impact on the entire
team with the reality that the State
Library must show a specif with the
reality that the State Library must show
a specific amount allocated by the
general fund to to reach the threshold
of Eligibility to receive federal
funding as required by the federal
program here we have focused on the
unfund of two vacant General funded
positions uh totaling
$168,000 126 and 174 in 27 combined with
a general fund cut of
15533 in 26 and
3510 in fiscal year 27 uh that's the
publication budget this combination of
cuts will prevent us from losing our
required Federal funding match and will
avoid the need for cutting critical
services like our inter Library Loan
program or our talking books program if
we have to make any further Cuts we will
need to close public access to the main
library building for at minimum one day
a week as additional positions would be
cut necessita necessitating this drastic
action the division of forest and lands
is home to our forest rangers who are
general fund
in September we submitted a budget that
unfund one vacant forest ranger position
rather than cut the Rangers further as
we only have 10 in order to meet further
General funded cut targets we decided to
shift the funding of three generally
funded staff
positions in the forest management
Bureau to our revolving fund which is
called the forest management and
protection fund this fund is reliant on
our division's own revenues from Timber
harvests on state land under the
management of this agency the timber is
sold to private logging companies and
Sawmills throughout through a
competitive bidding process the revenue
covers not only most of our forest
management Bureau staff but also
critical expenses such as vehicles and
computer equipment for most of the
division besides being the primary
funding source of the forest management
Bureau the timber sale program also has
a significant economic impact on the
public sector on average it generate
$160,000 of Timber tax an oh this is I
screwed this one up Timber tax annually
distributed to the towns where the
timber is harvested if you're following
along that was a
glitch additionally dozens of logging
and trucking companies benefit as do the
local sawmills that rely on state lands
to procure their wood supply Studies
have shown an economic multiplier
upwards of $30 for every $1 of revenue
generated from the sale of Timber
moving generally funded Forest
management Bureau positions to funding
from Timber sale Revenue in the forest
management and protection fund will
reduce general fund costs by nearly
$520,000 in fiscal year 26 and
27 there is a strong concern however
that we are now over obligating the
forest management and protection fund to
take on more operational expenses than
it can sustain over the long
term we have also considered shifting
Wildfire Patrol position costs to
federal funds to cover these
expenditures with Federal grant funds
the fire tower positions would go
unfunded and thereby eliminate 10
part-time seasonal forestry Aid
positions who staff the fire towers for
fire detection this would be in addition
to not funding a full-time forest ranger
position and reducing the Wildfire fight
detection budget by
62% the current and proposed budget
reductions will have an impact on the
Department's ability to provide Wildfire
detection suppression prevention and
Forest Law Enforcement throughout the
state while the division of Parks and
Recreation is operationally self-funded
they have stepped up to support the
traditionally General funded Bureau of
historic sites they will support this
Bureau with $
56,600 and
5988 respectfully for the years 26 and
27 the impact simply put removes money
from the park system uh which is used to
uh keep up with maintenance
infrastructure improvements and their
rainy day
fund finally from the commissioner's
office we are profer up a critical
position unfund our funded vacant
in-house Legal Professional position the
dncr is engaged in hundreds of contracts
leases and other complex scenarios with
outside organizations regularly and we
depend heavily on the Office of the
Attorney General their legal counsil
team to support us in these endeavors
in determining that it would be
essential for us to have a full-time
dedicated legal representation resource
to keep up in a timely fashion with our
legal needs to that end we worked with
doj to craft a position to support us
internally and provide a more efficient
tether to their Department without this
position we rely solely on the precious
time assigned to us by doj filling this
position would be a win-win for both
agencies but we will have to wait until
we can afford this opportunity and I
want to end by saying very proud of the
hard work my team has taken on to bring
forward a budget that while is a little
painful it is in line with the goals of
the state to ensure a fiscally
responsible budget for the next
Byam thank you very much you're welcome
and we're here to answer questions okay
so let's go to page
um so as I said General funds looks like
it's um in line with what you spent last
year which is good um the uh I want to
ask federal funds seem to be declining
right so uh last year it was 7.2 this
year it's budgeted at 8.9 probably I'm
guessing it doesn't come in that level
but it's going to only six million so um
are we losing some kind of federal
grants or something is in thanks for the
question so we're not actually losing
grants in this case what we did was we
sort of dialed some of the
Appropriations that we typically
estimate going forward uh and and tried
to bring them back down to a more
realistic number relative to what's
actually spent on a yearly basis there
were years where we were hoping to
receive significant amounts of federal
funds which we will do but we also have
many years to spend them but we were
budgeting the whole amount on a yearly
basis so what I tried to do this time
around was bring that number back to be
more realistic to what we actually spend
on a yearly basis so that's all that
really is we haven't lost necessar neily
Federal funding that has been available
to us for for many years we've just
tried to budget and appropriate in a
little more of a conservative fashion to
stay in step with what actually go out
the door I see so what you're saying is
I see six million of spending but the
amount coming in could be seven it could
be five it could be some other number it
can fluctuate cor absolutely so again
trying to stay in step with what we know
at a at a point in time but those
numbers do change I get it yes now in
other funds which I assume is the park
fees mostly um maybe other kinds of fees
uh you're expecting to go up 5 million a
year is roughly a little more than 10%
looks like 12% or so um from what you
got last year so is that realistic are
you raising fees well there's two parts
to two answers to that one yes fees were
raised fees have changed um through a
series of fee package submissions that
have occurred
um but this number the the difference
that you see is
essentially budgeting 24 is actuals 25
is an adjusted authorized there is an
element of of estimating in that figure
um we're hopeful to to meet those
targets but we may not with the increase
in the fees we hope to come close to
that number and then going into 26 and
27 we tried to keep that flat keep that
consistent and that's why those numbers
look the way they do what what kind of
changes have there been in fees so one
example is a $1 an hour increase at our
Hampton Beach toll uh parking meters so
that went up from $2 to $3 and we
automated the system um so that people
could be on the beach reading their book
and just put more money in with their
phone uh which is which is um something
that they that is uh very uh appreciated
um so that was an incremental change um
we just went to fiscal with a couple of
tweaks to the C Mountain um ski package
for next season again really incremental
but we're you know over the last year or
two we've been scrutinizing our fee
package so that we don't create harm in
uh and and overwhelm people but we tweak
a couple things here and there that that
really benefit us when when the um the
wage increase for state employees
happened it was really important that we
were able to dial up the Hampton meters
because the general fund you know didn't
pay for that wage increase and we were
able to compensate for it with that in
increment okay so one thing we we look
at to see um if people are on track sort
of is we look at um what they spent in
2019 compared to what they're spending
today and um so fiscal year 25 to 2019
is six years and in that period your
general funds went up 4
36% now that compares to like 30% if you
look at uh inflation and and growth of
the state so you're considerably over in
the use of General funds lately sort of
uh I'll speak to one point and then I'll
let Chris correct me um so uh over the
last couple years our general fund
allocation for the Arts has increased um
it doubled um so that's one area where
we were able to get support from
governor cunu and legislation to to dial
that up um which had not seen an
increase in a very long time so that's
one example okay yeah and that would be
thank you that would be the most
significant example uh that went from a
half a million dollars a year to a
million dollars a year so that added a
million dollars per bium to the general
fund alone between that period and and
this period um we of course know that
with the with the pay increases of of
course that probably accounts for with
the 30% average that you just mentioned
yeah we're a little bit higher than that
uh not only because of the increase in
the Arts which was a substantial
component of that but other small uh
changes such as for example the forest
Protection Bureau which received a
significant increase uh in Pay due to an
allocation adjustment for pay for that
particular group um as a group two uh
staff so that was a substantial amount
as well those are some of the the pieces
that would contribute to that amount
higher than the average but I can get
you the details if you would like just
to to do that further analysis to to
clarify that for you okay do you have a
lot of group two
employees relatively speaking no I think
the total is I think 11 or 12 um Forest
ranges out of 200 out of 200 yes yeah
okay all right shall we go to page
something else repres
wer you show as a number of employees
about 200 but when I get the information
from the treasurer of how many paychecks
went to your department it's like 500
going in seasonally up to 800 almost 900
and then yes back to 5 we like to give
our employees multiple just kidding
there's a lot of temps sure no we
probably not the Right
audience how does she how you give out
500 so we have so many seasonal
employees um that goes up to 800
something in in this summertime yes but
it's you still only showed 200 here but
this shows most of the months of the
year it's 500 so we I mean we have we
have winter seasonals as well at Canon
for example um and um yeah so I'm happy
to clarify so yeah the 200 uh plus 200
well be 202 I think it was 210 this past
by anym uh is is a combination of
permanent classified and unclassified
positions only we we also have about 30
full-time temps that are budgeted on a
banal basis and then of course beyond
that is many mo many many temp positions
uh used for firefighting which H which
occurs at different periods of the year
but most significantly keeping those
numbers up is the 300 plus that are
employed during the winter for Canon as
seasonals and then the over 800 that
occur during the summertime uh for the
park system so that it big recruiting
job thank you yes how many of the 210
are vacant
currently we have I have that list right
me of the
210 and that would be just the
full-time I'm sorry excuse me just one
second here my paper is yeah that's all
right it's actually in the package uh
that I
here we go this would be uh page
six uh in the package there are
full-time three four five six seven 8 N9
10 11 A Lot 12 there are 12 permanent
classified and one unclassified combined
total uh currently
vacant oh I see
most of which are in the Parks and
Recreation division which is an other
funded uh
position or other funded positions so
what is this long list then uh this list
was provided uh to identify
all vacant funded
positions uh currently uh in
fy2 uh both full-time and
part-time permanent classified and
temporary oh I see so all these
firefighters are temporary correct in
case you have a fire
right okay makes sense I see thank you
all right let's go to page let's see
here um
all
right so administ were there were there
vacancies in 2024 in the administration
or maybe there are some still now uh
there is currently one vacant uh
position in administration it is the
attorney position which we are actually
26 27 yes that's the only vacant
position right now in our but we're not
getting rid of
it yes we're not we are we unfunded it
UNF funding it for 26 and right but we
didn't um remove the position we haven't
removed the position because the 19 is
still 19 we were we simply uh retained
it as an unfunded FTE okay so Jack maybe
make a note of that
one okay
um representative evil yeah just on on
UNF funding just because something is
unfunded it doesn't mean that it's not
perhaps vital to your
operations C I'm sorry for for this one
specifically we worked really hard to
achieve this position and fund it um as
I mentioned we worked closely with doj
um we have a really close working
relationship with the team over there um
but our workload is immense um and I
think we could we could open our own Law
Firm at the
dncr um so I'd like someday to get back
to a place where we can have that
position I think it would streamline a
lot of our legal documents it would be
nice to have somebody with a a legal
interpretation at some of our meetings
um and when we uh when we develop
relationships you know let's do it right
the first time um so to speak so I think
that it's an important worthy position
uh and we'll just take a knee at for now
and hope that we can we can fulfill that
in the future what what sort of legal
conundrum are there that you just to
name a couple um
well we do a lot of of leasing of space
so the SE Coast Science Center is at
Odon uh Point State Park um we have the
observatory up at Mount Washington State
Park um we we work uh with um with well
we have special use permits that you
know could be a family reunion or uh you
know a a huge um swimathon that raises
millions of dollars um and so we have a
staff that's working operationally in
state parks but it would be really good
to shore up some of these types of
agreements and arrangements so that
we're handing something to doj to review
that's already in good shape and not
expending a lot of their mental capacity
to sort of walk us through every time we
get a new
situation okay so you'd prefer retain
this
position thank you Mr chair thank you
for uh coming in uh just a follow up on
on representative Evil's Point um you
did make a point in your statement that
the um the general funded position in
the uh arts division is um would would
create a um an impact
um um is that you know it sounds like
with the attorney you've have a
workaround figured out is this one uh in
a little different class that it's it's
really going to
get down into the
bone well you
know I would I would love to fill that
position because there's enough work to
do and with a small staff as I mentioned
you know a small staff you take one out
then then it's noticeable if it was a
staff of 150 and we took one out the the
workload could be shared a little little
bit um easier so uh you know for this we
we took our task uh to heart and we
looked at what we could manage and this
is a scenario where thankfully we have a
really Dynamic close-knit um Arts staff
that you know doesn't mind picking up
the load and um and moving forward you
know so that our constituents don't
notice the difference that's really the
key right what can we what can we cut um
or get rid of but without sacrificing
the customer service aspect so in the
Arts uh division they work a lot with
you know Grant giving and and sort of
assisting uh organizations and artists
around the state um by losing this
position it it's going to be felt with
the staff but we're going to maintain
our our customer service um
representative cell thank you Mr chair
just curious on uh page
539 uh uh line 60 the benefits how we
how are you able to get the benefits
down like prob over close to 100,000 so
sure so you'll notice the salary line is
also significantly decreased we actually
uh for 26 27 we moved I believe six or
seven positions out of this accounting
unit into a different accounting unit so
you're seeing a significant reduction in
the salary and benefits lines in this
particular this particular grp okay
thank you yeah look at positions at the
bottom of the page
uh page 20
um so down at the bottom here we have um
conservation plate
funds um are we
expecting we got only
um uh 560,000 in 24 but we're expecting
900,000 ongoing is the cost of a
conservation plate gone up or no no
somebody so yeah so what you're seeing
there is you're seeing a figure uh
related to a combination of of agency
income the next page actually uh adds an
additionally 9,000 to tie out that total
of
647 relative to what was spent in that
fiscal year we actually receive a
significant amount more in that
accounting unit um but this the actuals
that are depicted here only show the
revenue relative to what was actually
spent so you're not seeing the full
picture this is a this is a a dedicated
fund there's a fund balance in this
accounting unit uh in the last couple of
years we've received actually over a
million dollars uh for our portion to oh
and this you sort of transfer out to
other things is the well no we keep we
keep the funding in the accounting unit
um but we put an estimate an
appropriation estimate uh in this case
$900,000 but we've been posting stronger
Revenue I see and the big well so the
big increase here has been this uh
building contractual maintenance
buildings and grounds you you added to
that went from zero to 2,
200,000 I'm sorry is which which class
class 48 class
48 um 0 to 200,000 Zer in 2024 yes
understood okay right so again that
that's 24 is actuals so what that means
is although we keep money in the fund
balance for the purpose of Maintenance
particularly uh related to the Bureau of
historic sites uh there was no actual
spending that occurred in fy2 24 I think
most of it was encumbered through
Contracting but because of the time it
takes to contract to get through the
process to get everything encumbered
there essentially was no spending that
occurred so it's projects more than
correct clean maintenance projects yes
okay all right good so let's go to
page
forestry page
546 Community Forestry um um we have our
state Forester with us Patrick would you
perfect uh my name is Patrick Hackley
I'm the state Forester for the division
of forest and lands
um a community Forester so we have uh we
have seven bureaus within our division
and one of them is the Urban and
Community forestry Bureau and so we have
a full-time individual a Forester who
provides education and Outreach uh we do
a lot of school tree
plantings uh we work with project
Learning Tree um uh mostly with uh like
I said with private land owners schools
um we partner with UNH Cooperative
Extension um this is a u federally
funded position so we we couldn't do
that work without the um Federal pass
through funding from the US Forest
Service oh even though it says inter
agency
transfer it's still
Federal yeah let me clarify so it is
it's federally funded but the funding
itself resides in a different accounting
unit so in order to get the funding over
to where the position is we use this
inter agency transfer mechanism to yeah
most of this forestry stuff does look
Federal
yeah yeah except well let's go to Forest
leg as long as you're here page 548
Forest
Legacy so Forest Legacy is a federal
program as well and that provides
funding to uh purchase conservation
easements from willing land owners who
wish to sell the development rights to
their property and keep it in working
Forest but did we lose a giant Grant cuz
that we're spending a big number in 2024
it's uh it it it U fluctuates
significantly and these deals can be in
the millions of dollars so some some
years we have like 1.5 or 2 million in
the account and other years we don't
because they're very they're targeted
based on an application process and then
the US Forest Service decides whether
they're going to fund it or not it's
competitive nationally uh competitive
and then that funding is awarded if they
find it to be worthy and then we proceed
it takes about three years from start to
finish you find a place to buy and then
you ask the feds could I have money for
this very simply
yeah so what's the purchase that you had
in
2024 2024 it's probably 2.3 million I
see that was probably yeah that's right
Chris it was the Dundee Forest up in the
um Jackson intervail area it was
actually three Parcels we worked with um
many times we have to work with a uh a
partner because of the complexity of the
application so for that one we worked
with the Trust for Public Lands and we
have one in the in the queue now called
Andre scogan Valley I don't know if that
appears in the budget but that's um I
think 1.6 million and that's in the gorm
area no and then just to to clarify so
this is a good example of what I
mentioned at the beginning about how
we're managing the federal
Appropriations because of the
fluctuating of this type of a purchase
what we don't want to do is build a $2.3
million appropriation in the budget we
don't even know how much is going to be
and we don't even know if we're going to
get it so typically what happens is we
wait until the award occurs through a
series of of actions and then we bring
it as a as an accept and expend to the
fiscal committee that's the normal
practice for these types of things thank
you on page 552 there's Forest um
protection uh 13 employees what's that
Forest protection is the forest rangers
we've been talking about so that's where
our oh there's one vacant or something
that's the unfunded position oh one
okay
um northern region
headquarters you're you're double
[Music]
heat yeah um so the northern region is
our Lancaster office and we um we have
uh our forest ranger staff located there
we have about four Rangers out of that
office uh we also have uh one Parks
division staff uh we also are the
landlords to fishing game and UNH
Cooperative Extension there and I
believe we are in the market for a new
boiler uh so I don't know if that
anything to do with the increased cost
of heat but we we do need to replace the
boiler there that could be a burn some
wood we do burn wood there actually we
do in the garage yeah if the State Fire
Marshall will let us
continue
um
[Music]
okay
so yes and this Northeastern
coordination
Center yeah so that is I believe that's
also federally funded and that is um
what we call Our Kind of our
mobilization uh partnership with the US
Forest Service so that individual works
for us but is um housed at the US Forest
Service Office in Campton at the White
Mountain National Forest headquarters so
when we have requests from neighboring
states and the maritime Canadian
maritimes
that individual mobilizes uh works with
um our our conquered office and other
states to put together fire Crews and
get them shipped off to the various
States including out west so it's really
kind of like a dispatch position and
it's temp it's a temp so it's you're
just sort of estimating what it could be
is that kind of what it is yeah
basically because it's way down it's way
up from what you actually spend in 2020
24 budgeting right but
okay but it's just a guess I guess okay
Mr chair can I ask a question I had to
represent M uh thanks um in that area
why is the uh benefit expense so
high relative I mean there's no
Personnel
costs uh well so to to clarify that is a
a temp it's a called a full-time temp um
which means it it is budgeted as
essentially a full-time employee which
means it's eligible for full benefits so
when we budget it we do have to budget
full
benefits along with that position um the
disparity you're seeing between 24 and
25 is essentially what Patrick has kind
of alluded to is it's really based on
its its need the demand for that
position to function um but we have to
start with the position and then you
know as time allows depending on on how
things go there may not be a demand for
that many hours uh to keep that position
fully employed throughout the course of
a of a full year okay this budget
depicts essentially a 12-month full-time
employee
okay all
management so we're adding agency
income where there used to be General
funds
yes yeah so that's what the commissioner
mentioned in her opening
remarks um uh accounting unit 3505 is
our forest management protection fund
it's a revolving
fund um it consists of largely Timber
Revenue income but also revenue from the
sale of seedlings from our State Forest
Nursery uh also um uh Communications
that's more of a kind of goes in and
goes out to our communication sites but
we have um uh communication leases all
over the state on our mountain tops U
Camp leases seasonal camps we have about
going say
110 seasonal camps uh 91 of them are up
in Nash stream and then um there's half
a dozen or so over in onog so it's
probably under 100 um they're they run
anywhere from 1,000 to $2,000 a year so
those all go into that fund as well
good
[Music]
um let's go to I'm going to skip ahead
to
um so um is this somebody who like came
in partway through the year or something
like that CU it's it looks like one
person but the spending for for salary
is taking a big
jump this is for conservation asement
stewardship
yes
570 570 so just to clarify again uh
actuals in
24 uh represent a period of time that an
employee worked obviously the position
was open for some period of time FY 24
so it did not incur a full Year's worth
of salary and benefits uh fy2
again is an estimate based on that
position uh salary and benefits at that
uh labor grade and step uh going into uh
26 and 27 it looks like the position has
been estimated at a higher St higher
salary probably due to some an
adjustment in the um uh lab not the so
the person you hired was more senior
than you thought you were going to get
or something like that that can happen
that Canen where you end up bring
somebody in at a higher step only
because of their expertise which
typically the budget when the position
is vacant it's a step one right but a
lot of times when someone comes in if
they have experience they're going to
come in at a higher amount okay but here
you had to add general
fund yes this particular one uh does
have a small component of General funds
built into it although uh we we reduced
it it was 5050 in this bium and we've
reduced it to be a much smaller portion
General funding in this in this
right
um so on page 572 and
573 you you sort of
ended you moved General
funds or you move the pro natural
heritage
Bureau right you um a natural heritage
Agency
Inc yeah you kind of move things around
here yes yes so you notice that so what
we did was within 2103 accounting which
is at the towards the bottom of the page
that was that's the primary natural
heritage Bureau accounting unit um we
have Personnel in that accounting unit
but there were different mixes of
funding so what we did in this case was
we said let's identify the the general
funded uh folks and move them into their
own accounting unit so we we separated
to to
346 and that's what that's for although
there is a component of their salary
benefits that's also being funded by
some other agency income that's being
transferred into that accounting unit
but in doing so we were able to to set
it up so that
2103 no longer has any general funding
in it it is only a fund mix of agency
income inter agency transfers and
transfers of funding from other agencies
so it was a way to just isolate the
general funded component of this account
uh to so that it would have uh better
visibility and tracking without mixing
too many sources of funding in the
natural heritage Bureau representa evil
yeah um to what ex I know we're not
talking about hb2 today but to what
extent are the changes in hb2 reflected
in
hb1 uh at this time everything that was
uh going going to be done relative to
hb2 is reflected in hb1 in the case of
the with an exception in the case of the
natural heritage Bureau one of the
actions that was going to be taken was
to move two of the positions that
currently are employed from the natural
heritage Bureau to be employed at
Environmental Services however both of
those positions were full-time temporary
positions that were approved through a
fiscal action so they were never
reflected in the hb1 even before this
change was made so you we won't see any
changes in HB one relative to the
natural heritage bu Bureau based on the
actions that have already occurred
however there is going to be a need to
make a change uh further and I have that
that's part of the submission uh that I
have attached and we can go over that
these are some additional budget
requests that we have one of the actions
will be to move one of the positions uh
from the natural heritage Bureau
actually in accounting unit
347 uh will will be moved out of if that
is done then hb1 you will see 3407 be
eliminated as well yeah all right so
this is um this letter you have on page
eight uh let's take a look starting on
page eight correct all right this is the
these are the requests that we have have
submitted uh budgetary changes all right
well let's uh maybe we should talk about
this just so we don't run out of
time sure right now I mean
okay so going through the first uh
number one is basically establishing
budgets for Connecticut Lake
headquarters um we have endowments that
are used to fund uh the cost of
Maintenance stewardship and and other
components of Connecticut League
headquarters or functions um we did not
initially submit these requests as
budgetary requests during the agency
phase or even the governor's phase
because we were still working with
treasury to ensure that we understood
exactly how much was in these endowments
that they were sufficient and that we
could move forward we're also
communicating with uh the fish and game
Bureau who also has a stake in these
endowments everybody's in agreement at
this point of how much is available
there's a significant amount of money
available in these endowments so what
we'd like to do is go ahead and request
to to to proceed with putting budgets in
place for the Connecticut Lake
headquarters accounting units and that's
that's what you're seeing here in the
request um the second component number
two is related to positions that were
initially moved as part of the hb2 that
you've just mentioned uh the
consolidation of the permitting process
in the course of preparing for that
through the governor's phase it was
believed that two of the positions in
the division of historical resources
would also need to be moved to support
that function upon further discussions
it was determined no these positions are
not appropriate to be moved uh however
it was too late uh in the governor's
phase to get the moved back so they ask
us when you go just request to have them
put back so that that this second
section is essentially requesting to
move those two positions from the
Department of Environmental Services
back into our division of historical
resources um and I've identified the
accounts and the positions can you can
you put show me the page for this page
10 no no no I'm sorry yeah I I jumped a
little bit ahead on the connectic
headwaters
um okay page 10 of the submission if
halfway down the page uh section two
yeah it identifies the request to move
the two positions it explains
essentially what happened and and what
we'd like to to do
no okay but where is it in house build
one do we know yes in house it is in
house bill one if you were to go to the
section of the budget where the division
of historical resources are and I can
give you the page number so you can see
federal see them
sorry okay so you'll notice on page 600
one on page 600 under accounting unit
1444 you'll notice that the head count
of the number of permanent classified
positions from 25 to 26 goes from 4 to
three yes and you'll notice in on page
601 under
1445 the permanent classified position
count goes from 7 to six so those are
the those were the two positions that
were reduced there was one in each one
of these accounting units so we're
asking for those to be restored back
into this accounting init and and that
yes well yeah right but one of them cost
me general fund yes one of them is
General funds and actually it is an
unfunded position oh in 26 27 so it'll
be moved back the count will will change
but the dollars in that accounting un it
will not I
see okay um currently vacant I see this
the second
one yes okay I see it's vacant and
unfunded
yes okay all right next one and then
finally the the third request that we
have is what I just mentioned about the
natural heritage Bureau uh through the
the changes that are occurring in hb2
relative to the pering process
consolidation they're also going to be
moving the the fund The Authority for
the natural heritage Bureau fund uh
under their Authority as well currently
because we have a position residing
under that fund uh if the fund goes over
to environmental services so does the
position so that position needs to
actually move move over to the
Department of Environmental Services so
we've specifi we've identified the
position number and the purpose so are
you transferring some of these funds to
Environmental Services all of all of the
funding will go over to Environmental
Services with the position from their
sources to their to their it'll it'll go
I don't know if the fund is going from
what I understand the fund itself is not
going to be liquidated but the authority
over that use of that fund will transfer
to environmental services and I see okay
so um Jack you'll remind me of these
things when we come to vote on this okay
good all right um let's go back to the
questions um page
581 um you're predicting that that your
utilities expense at Canon is going to
go down by a
third that seems Cor seems pretty
aggressive very excited really good news
oh okay we
renegotiated ah with the electric
company through D Das yes it's a
significant savings can you do that for
me too we'll talk upine
okay all right so so you think this is
is accurate yes yes yeah okay good very
good all right
589 yes representative evil so just um
on in hb2 you have the change relative
to the Canon Mountain
Tramway correct yes that's 18 million so
you just are needing more time I just
saw the date well I can I can clarify
the language the purpose of the language
in hb2 and then the commissioner wants
to talk that's fine so all all the
language in hb2 is doing is saying that
at the end of the bium whatever
Appropriations are remaining aing from
this warrant that have not been expended
will lapse back to the general fund
that's the only purpose of that language
um so we achieved an allocation of$ 18
million for the
tram and this says that that 18 million
will revert back to the general fund and
then in hb2 I believe they've put um a
suggestion of 20 million hb25 hb25 sorry
so we'll have a
conversation um at that point to try to
secure that $20 million for the tram um
just for situational awareness uh you
know the the tram is sort of like uh
very complicated scenario where we can't
just you know buy parts for a little bit
of money now and then just buy parts we
have to buy we have to redo the tram um
and that's one big ticket item um so
we've been working with um um we did an
RF RFP we got a bid back with some
really um helpful notes uh from the two
companies one company bid one didn't the
bid came back at 33 million which is way
more than 18 million um and so we've
learned from that and one of the Lessons
Learned is if we can verify the safety
of some
concrete posts foundations um that and
verify it to the at an engineering level
that that allows uh a vendor to make a
much lower bid on the tram so we're
trying to achieve that validation before
we go back out to bid I see so it'll
take another year or something but yeah
okay I get it representative Ms um thank
you can I just follow up on that and and
my apologies if I'm not if I'm a little
slow on the uptake here so there's $18
million that was approved for the
Tramway
for the current bium yes that money is
not being spent so that's coming back to
the general fund in the in the current
bium the FY 2425 bani yes okay
um and then there's $20 million
allocated in the capital budget for
2627 in the
governor's capital budget so we will go
before the capital budget committee and
try to secure their support for that
okay and and there and so then there's
nothing in this budget that we're
reviewing um there's no money for for
the Canon Mountain Tramway corre this
budget correct okay thank you so Jack
this makes me wonder if house Ways and
Means knew about this 18
million in their estimates yeah
represent where here Does it show the
monies that are transferred from Mount
sop to
can and how much might that be that
would be accounting unit uh
3705 on page let me see if I can find it
for
you oh I'm sorry so I just remember so
that's not an operating budget item you
won't see
the uh the budget for the Canam mountain
and capital impr it's essentially the
Canam Mountain Capital Improvement fund
so what that is is it's a fund that is
used to uh Provide support for
maintenance costs at up at Canon
Mountain authorized up to six million
dollar in bonding the revenue from the
sonap lease is used to pay the debt
service on that bonding um but that is
not built into the operating budget per
se it is a
separate request that occurs uh at the
beginning of every fiscal year where I I
make a request to appropriate what I
think is the amount of Debt Service in
concert with the treasury to get that
number and then I budget the the same
amount for Revenue um you know and the
belief of course and it has been strong
is we've been receiving revenue from
that lease in excess of our debt service
so we' built up a pretty good balance
which is about how much right now we
this year I think we we just posted um
uh8 over $800,000 in
Revenue okay uh representative
Griffin yeah thank you Mr chair and
thanks for taking my question obviously
of all the divisions we look at weather
is a huge factor with you people and um
I'm wondering whether it's also a factor
and expenses it obviously can affect
your Revenue a poor winter and a poor
summer really affects your revenue does
it also affect your expenses
proportionately thank you great question
um we've had a great winter so far by
the way and revenue at Canon is is is up
which is awesome um one of the reasons
we try to keep a healthy Park fund is
for that reason right if it's a rainy
summer um the parks license plates also
help us um predict you know our budget
better because uh the of the support
from uh folks who buy that license plate
but yes weather of of course um creates
costs at Hampton Beach you know this the
winter storms at Hampton Beach put a
number on our parking lots as
representative Ms must notice um we have
to do a lot of prep preparation to get
uh the beach safe for the summer um I'd
also say that I've learned a ton about
CTS in this position and um uh you know
weather um puts a strain on our CTS um
uh both for our roads that we manage in
and out of parks but for our trail
system um too so Bridges and culverts um
get expensive in a hurry um we you know
we try our best to um catch up with all
of this stuff in in in time for a season
which holds us accountable really
because you know if things aren't fixed
in time for ATV season our phones are
ringing
um so we really do try to get ahead of
the problem as as seasonally as possible
um but yeah it it the we weather for
sure is a is a cost
Factor
yeah yes Mr Le representative Le thanks
Mr chairman so one of your earlier
statements you mentioned the cutback and
like fire support I think like
62% the Staffing of like what 12 fire
Towers uh knowing that you had like a
record number of fires last year yeah
and that could happen again how would
you handle the funding of that if you
had to staff up fire Towers or found
ourselves in a drought as we have in the
past internally about this in particular
um New
Hampshire this season was very busy um
not only in New Hampshire but in helping
our neighbors to the South and to the
north you know fires in Canada fires in
Massachusetts um we really are Regional
Support Network
um and uh one one blessing to um to
fires is that we get to send our staff
out west to really get some excellent
training and bring back their knowledge
here to the New England region uh so we
take advantage of those opportunities if
you will um so we have a very
sophisticated and and and well-trained
team that we share our knowledge base um
beyond our our division walls with the
local fired departments and our um in
our regional uh uh Partners but Patrick
I'll let you speak a little bit more
about that can I just comment we may be
on page 558 State Fire assistance is
that right and that's going up this is
federal funds but it's it looks like the
FED federal government is putting a lot
more money into this right um our forest
Protection Bureau where our Rangers
reside or where they work that's their
um division
uh we while it's one of our largest
generally funded uh sections of our
division it also is well funded by
federal funds that we pass through to
the towns for equipment purchases we
also have a federal um uh equipment
program that we administer so when uh
fire trucks engines Jeeps become
available on the federal they have a
kind of a online inventory our people
find out what the towns need secure the
the equipment and deliver them to the
towns all with the the support of
federal
funding um so yeah it's it's a great
program and and the towns depend on our
Bureau and our Rangers for training we
provide equipment with water pumps and
techniques for
suppression um so when they're not
enforcing Timber harvesting laws or
engaged in um
uh fire suppression and detection
they're training they're doing workshops
with the towns I did want to get back to
representative leishman's question
though um it is a concern so just to be
very brief it is a concern with these um
increasingly dry Summers and this was a
record-breaking fall as the commissioner
alluded to fortunately we we were about
average in New Hampshire but our
neighbors to the South uh Massachusetts
and Connecticut had record years
so so one of our sergeants who uh we we
miss that's the unfunded position our
Sergeant he took a position with
Connecticut as their Force fire
supervisor within two weeks when he got
there there are fires all across
Connecticut and uh he had to call in a
helicopter from Maine part of that
network of support we have with the
other states and uh they they mobilized
their National Guard um and I think the
the governor declared a state of
emergency on at least a couple of what
we call Red Flag days when the humidity
relative humidity is low and the
temperatures are high and there's a wind
a steady wind I think I don't know that
the limit but has to be a certain amount
of those three factors called the Red
Flag Day so there are there record
number of dry fall days that um in in
Massachusetts there they had two fires
are over a thousand acres in size which
is unusual for a new small New England
State I guess to my question where would
the money come from if you needed to
staff the fire tower get people out in
the field right so we have two buckets
of money we have General funds and we
have federal funds so we're we're
toggling between those two buckets to
fund either the Wildfire
patrols or the the fire tower Staffing
but we can't do both so we had to make a
choice so that's the situation we're in
with with the budget cuts I you know I
we could seek perhaps additional grant
funding from the federal side but I'm
sure all of you know the the Federal
grant funding is is under duress these
days as well so that bucket is less
certain than General funding in New
Hampshire I did have another question Mr
chairman I know we're getting close to
the have 30 seconds perhaps uh I heard
from a friend of mine with the timber
land Owners Association and you talked
about selling your Timber off to the saw
mills and he informed me that the mills
in Canada aren't taking product now
because of the tariff issue they don't
want to take New Hampshire logs or us
logs and not be able to sell them on the
return trip have you heard anything
about that or is that a significant
concern that we can't move our lumber to
Canada because the Mills AR accepting it
I hadn't heard it until now but it's not
surprising that happened four years ago
in the in the previous Trump
Administration there was some issues
with moving logs to Canada
um yeah so they'll find other markets
proba for their for their Timber but the
Canadians pay pretty well so that that's
a frustration for the land owners
selling the timber as well as the the
loggers and Foresters involved yeah
thank you Mr chairman thanks okay um
yeah we're almost out of time so let me
589 um and 590 I guess um what are these
grants um National recreational Trails
fund um
we're doing grants that are more than
doubling um and also contracts for
doubling yeah so thanks for the question
so th this one here um these are these
are grants that we receive actually the
Department of Transportation the federal
do gives a gives a huge block grant to
the New Hampshire do and then New
Hampshire dot allocat so we actually
receive an amount from that uh straight
from New Hampshire do the numbers that
are budgeted are based on the figures
that they give us to say that this is
how much we have to give you for 26 27
so that's where these numbers come from
we don't make these numbers up they we
actually uh receive them from New
Hampshire do uh then it's up to us to
basically turn around and budget and you
can you'll notice that a substantial
portion of it is is actually grants to
municipalities communities and the and
the like so that's potentially doing
what for for uh maintenance of of trails
the trails Bureau yeah essentially okay
yeah these are for Trails for clubs uh
snowmobile ATV Etc I see so it's just um
do gets a big General sort of Federal
Grant and they decide how much to give
you is that yeah there's a formula for
for it but yes we receive a portion of
that but is it that the feds gave them
twice as much or it's
just I assume so I don't talk to do to
ask okay so I I can ask division to yeah
we're can I know we're out of time but
could you just give us just sort of a
snapshot of your thoughts on the
condition of our state parks I know they
get an awful lot of use and I know with
budget cuts maintenances challenging and
I'm just you know curious thank you so
we do things the New Hampshire way in
New Hampshire and we are one of two
states I believe that are operationally
self-funded for our Park system which
has worked really well for us especially
when we have to tighten things up with a
general fund um we uh have you know an
endless list of Maintenance uh we we
always will um but we we are
strategizing every year and and we go to
Capital uh with you know our top
priorities the capital budget committee
and they've over the the years have been
very gracious um you know profer up uh
Investments of a couple million dollars
uh which helps um it helps um make sure
that you know we prioritize our safety
situations first um we benefited from a
very generous arpa allocation which
allowed us to uh to grow some of our
campgrounds which then provides more
Revenue um so we made one-time
Investments with arpa where we would get
a return on that investment so that's
that makes us feel a little optimistic
about how we're moving forward our
campgrounds are booked you know um 90%
of the time uh which is a good thing um
but we we need to uh be strategic about
how we're expanding and updating our
bathrooms bathrooms are very expensive
um and they're in remote areas um my
least favorite bathroom is on top of
Mount Washington cuz that's like not
supposed to be there um but yeah we I
think because we're oper operationally
self-funded and we've maintained a
healthy um State Park fund a rainy day
fund um we're able to be strategic
um we had to close Greenfield state park
for some Renovations um we just decided
we'll just instead of doing peace meal
we'll just close it for a season that
will impact our Revenue a little bit but
we we you know we planned for that um
and uh revenues right now we get a
weekly revenue report and uh it's it's
very optimistic um people love our state
parks um we have as we noted you know
several hundred seasonals well those
aren't brand new every year a lot of
them have worked with us for 20 30 40
years um so there's um there's a a a a
love for protecting these places um and
uh and as you know through pocket
pockets of communities around the state
are very passionate about their local
outdoor spaces and they hold us
accountable um so you know people adopt
their state parks as their own and I
wouldn't have it any other way because
it keeps us um on track and uh I'm sure
you hear about it if somebody's upset
with a parking lot or a bathroom or um
any any other experience that they have
that's not acceptable we've worked
really hard on training um on on sort of
the the the um customer service part of
state parks uh to professionalize our
operations and when we go to I go to a
manager meeting twice a year and um they
it's a professional operation it's it's
really impressive it's not just um show
up and and mow the lawn it's a lot more
more than that and it's it's doing very
well do you do any kind of joint
marketing programs with the division of
travel and tourism so if you recall
dread really tied travel and tourism
with state parks it was all under one
agency um and so there was a bit of a a
learning curve when that was untangled
but we now um have our own marketing
contract for state parks um the short
answer is yes we like to be very similar
with what travel and tourism is doing so
that we can all benefit from um you know
a similar approach um with our marketing
um but uh yeah we we we I think per RSA
we're still um connected in in terms of
messaging and marketing uh to make sure
that we're not saying two different
things um to the public yeah I'm just
trying to get feedback as to how
effective those things are I mean you
said we're doing well yeah getting
people in but is it that your marketing
their marketing or some combination you
don't know probably I don't I don't know
um I think that I think that's a or just
natural a fact a fascinating question
and and I think it's worthy of of
research we're so busy every day that we
haven't had the time to step back and do
some of that research but uh we're
aggressive with our with our marketing
all right well thank you commissioner
Stewart um I don't know if we'll have to
ask you back but we may so because you I
mean you have 65 Pages here so it's like
a lot in HB
yes yeah so certainly for hb2 we'll have
I won't go on any more vacations okay
thank you for the month of March at
least okay thank you all right um so is
is um commissioner Jasper here maybe
we're GNA be going to
242 hey
so nothing goes through the cracks here
how about executive office um that's us
but we probably won't see them like the
governor that's the governor yeah we saw
them at the uh bigger meeting at the
full Finance kind of kind
of if you looked at them there probably
be a small number here yeah oh fees here
oh is Community College under r no
two all right I'm sorry we're late
commissioner
um so I'm thank you for coming
commissioner so I'm I'm just just
reading your letter here um we currently
spend over
$350,000 on pet vending what does that
mean what do you what are you spend what
are you doing that oh what are we doing
well we uh spend a lot of time doing
inspections and followup there are you
know thousands and thousands I think you
know there are numbers in here about
55,000 animals that are transferred
around the state and we regulate the
people who uh are engaged in that and
those can be rescues or uh
for-profits um but they have standards
that the legislature has uh assigned
that they must meet and so we try to get
in twice a year but in reality if
somebody has a clean bill of health
we're probably only in these location
once a year but um there is a lot of
work that that goes with the trade and
um spend a lot of time on those who are
not complying with the laws and and have
problems so we spend you know probably
two and a
half um people within the
four uh of our four um yeah what am I
trying to say four veterinarian
technicians and excuse me I have had two
very poor nights of sleep we were in DC
got held over without our luggage uh and
on top of that I had a severe case of
gout and I could barely walk I thought
he was going to be pushing me through
the airport in a wheelchair I managed
and so I am not very sharp today so
forgive me but um yeah it's uh it is the
bane of our existence if we could find
somebody else to do pet vending and if
you find anybody who says they need
something else to do we're glad to give
them pet vending although we just did
develop our uh animal database where now
we're having um you know probably on
average about
120 certificates come through that on in
a day
is it something where most of the
problems you find are due to complaints
rather than due to inspections um there
are a lot of complaints but most of the
the problems I think we find are people
not meeting the the standards and a lot
of that has to do with when you're
having animals if you have untreated
surfaces and animals are scratching at
them it's a breeding ground for
bacterior disease and they're supposed
to be um painted or M um impervious to
to water to things like that and
improper paperwork a lot of times with
you know we've seen some where it says
it was a dog and then someplace else on
the same paperwork I might say it was a
cat so trying to figure out what are we
actually dealing with so paperwork is a
big issue and so yes represented M thank
you Mr chair and thank you for coming in
again um are the are the
requirements in this area that the
legisl has charged you with are they
still reasonable I mean are they
consistent with best practice in the
rest of the country I believe that that
they are there and there's nothing in
there the vast majority of our pet
vendors are able to meet the
requirements uh very easily one of the
the common things that we get from
people who aren't is well yeah but I'm
I'm doing good I'm doing good work well
there's not an exemption in the law for
doing good work you don't get to violate
the law just cuz you're trying to do
good so it's there's a lot of drama
literally there is a lot of drama
involved in
this are these vendors licensed they are
licensed if they so that's this $30,000
licensing that is correct I see so
you're proposing not to raise that but
more to have a per a per animal right
because that would make it proportional
based on the usage particularly of of
this multi-million dollar database that
we have and the
and the requirements to maintain it I'm
sure you all know how much uh the annual
licensing fees are so I understand all
right the next one pesticide product
registration um yes have not increased
the fees since 18 1980s okay so we're
talking about 40 years
um and the biggest one of the fees there
we can actually do within um in no yeah
yeah yeah that's the one that is in Rule
and uh we can produce a lot more Revenue
there uh and I I do propose that we go
forward with that as we're looking at
all of these so you don't need a don't
need change for that don't need on that
but the the other increases we do and we
can certainly okay provide and and again
I apologize I had expected to be in in
the office yesterday yeah and get all of
my ducks in a row sure and we can get
more detail my ducks are all over the
pond right
now 540,000
it's missing I thought you might be oh
yeah yeah
yeah 54,000 oh yeah so representative
camell points out here it's 540,000 or
is it 500 54,000 no it's 540 right yeah
okay oh apologize that was a late minute
because originally I thought that this
was in law and then I got a last minute
note and so got and typing I left off a
I don't think that'll work too well okay
um regulatory
Services um what's that so that uh deals
with
fertilizers um
pet
foods and there are a lot of those
products so
um yeah I don't remember how many is
177,000
products something like that I've got it
here
detail any animal feed product or um any
fertilizer that's registered in the
state of New Hampshire has to come
through our our department our division
yeah I'm I'm
but fertilizers as I say lming agents
pet food um
seed there's a whole lot of variety of
things
there
um weights and measures fees were set 25
years ago yeah what it's interesting
there and I'll give you the back story
is they used to be in statute they were
raised in fee by 30 33% in
20110 and the legislature didn't like
that and put them back to the the old
fees so that's how it's ended up
actually their the same as they were in
2000 so for a while they were higher
yeah for about a year okay and you
wanted so are you proposed to go up by a
third or what well they're actually
they're they're relatively small fees
the I think the rate of inflation at
2.75% it comes up to uh somewhere in the
vicinity of of 80% now these are
relatively small fees and so
um yeah they would go up significantly
but they would not be out of line with
what the states around us are charging
that was one of the things that I said I
I direct I directed my directors to look
at the rate of inflation and then to
look at what were other states charging
particularly around us and these would
be uh right in line with what our
surrounding states are charging gotcha
okay excellent okay
good um anybody want to ask a question
um so speaking of the general fund
um page 242 is the bottom line of your
budget and your use of General funds is
going up significantly not from what we
budgeted for fiscal year 25 but from
so
um can we budget for Less is the
question since it's since your spending
levels seems to be quite a bit less yeah
um so uh for accounting for a lot of
that would be the animal records
database uh which from uh fiscal year 24
was about in in the hundreds of
thousands 120,000 I believe and it's up
to 250,000 now and then we expanded that
through other divisions to update all of
our records databases and so modernizing
that process making more efficiencies
within the department uh just those two
things alone are close to about 400,000
of that increase and then when we have
uh added added salaries uh and benefits
going into that I think that makes up
the majority of of that increase um we
might be able to look a little further
but I don't think that the it's going to
be a massive savings without reducing
the services that we can provide so so
the amount you're paying doit is much
higher that's they're they're in those
are in our uh in our agent budget those
two pieces those software things correct
I see okay but it but it's
software um fee I don't know what it's
called subscription types things licing
impementation first round got main okay
and we have had increase in in Personnel
in there um and obviously the just the
10% increase um moving forward well so
we went yes and no right because that
was in 2024 so I think 2025 was only
another 2% right you're correct excuse
me but um but then there Step you know
there's some step step we did go through
this budget with a with a fine to comb
um you know realizing what we're were
facing and you know short of laying off
people that the legislature has
authorized which ultimately will just
create other other problems in a very
small agency um yeah I think we've done
a very responsible
uh budget uh obviously we're not pleased
with the um funds that we had that were
providing assistance for agricultural
land preservation for Farmer stress U
those were large Cuts but there's you
know there's no increase in Personnel
here and there's nothing that okay I
feel we could cut further on I
understand so on other funds you're
you're projecting an increase
of um $700 or more thousand what what's
that so I know with some of our federal
funds there are years that are and I'm
not sure if this is what not federal so
Federal looks like okay EXC Federal
looks like it's up a little but not much
right but I'm I'm asking about other F
oh
yeah Shel do you
no but those are all new none of those
ahead oh was was part of that the change
on the um what used to be the
product think so yeah so there was a
change um in a bill last year which
changed the percentage that that um of
other
funds so that more money was going to
the general fund from one category and
then that was moved into there and as a
result we cut cut general fund um
request for personnel so that we're
trying to within the
regulatory fund whatever that's called
and uh in pesticides more Personnel are
being funded from there but that has
brought in more to others simply because
of the fact that um more staying
there essentially we we shifted some uh
funding to from those uh dedicated funds
so it looks like there's more spending
coming out of the dedicated funds uh
rather than have it come out of General
funds so are you saying the balances and
the dedicated funds were growing faster
than were growing so Revenue was more
than you were expending and so therefore
you adjusted spending up correct okay I
understand okay good so let's go back to
guess let's see what are we looking for
time what we 207 yeah we don't have much
time so
um
maybe yeah let's go to page um
I'm looking for place where there's big
210 oh this is your database right so
this is your
software okay so you bought a new a new
computer the big one
yeah so um more temps or so animal
population
control is
that well I don't know it's Personnel
Services non-benefit what is
that are those temp part- timers or
so that was a part that was a parttime
position
um no I'm asking about class 45 oh
45 person
services but that doesn't make any sense
why we double we haven't doubled
this I think that's one of our dedicated
funds they're trying to out uh what she
said was it it's one of the dedicated
funds that again we're trying to spend
down but that wouldn't have come out of
yeah Personnel
Services oh yes correct there there's um
that is
fund but what is where's it going to
that's the question oh I think that was
a case again where we were
shifting
um where the employees salaries will
come in from and this this position um
essentially Works to a point and when
the budget for that salary Personnel
runs out the services stop for the Year
this person uh supports uh helping
low-income folks uh with the getting
spay and neuters of their animals to
reduce animal population and uh this
would allow us to continue out for the
full year it's sort of um giving some
leeway so that the position can provide
the services for longer during the year
this is where we actually increased to
100% so what was happening
excuse so we were paying veterinarians
about
80% of what it actually cost them to do
the spay and neuter we were
seeing um that number drop off dramatic
atically and so we were afraid we were
going to have a program with no
veterinarians to provide it so we upped
it to 100% um that was growing and I
think this is uh largely an estimate but
it's coming from a dedicated fund so it
doesn't make any any difference I think
it's the large increases due to the hope
and that we will have the money there to
be able to actually provide the services
I see so you you don't think the 500,000
is likely to be spent right no and
because it's a dedicated fund it doesn't
really matter you're saying yeah yeah
okay all
right
well so it does in the sense that if you
could use this dedicated fund for
something else in the budget that is now
generally funded then I could have some
more General funds for you know that is
where this is funded through the dog
licensing right right and there's a
dedicated um amount that goes there so
if you want to steal money from the dog
dog owners who are already not happy
about the fact that we are putting some
right I guess so yeah that's that is
always the well but I mean if there's
anything else you were doing with dog
licensing that was not that was
generally funded but you know yeah no we
are not okay well or you know some part
of your time goes to J goes to dog
licensing right so I have nothing to do
with that at all well totally a cat me
yeah no but I meant you know yeah no
because that's really really is there
the one person with an authorization for
10 hours a week when she's on
vacation um that stays totally internal
and got she deals with it all and uh Dr
Crawford does sign off on whether was
reasonable or not but that's about it
which is much easier now that we're
paying 100% not having to do the
math okay all
right well I think let me ask about
[Music]
oh so uh invasive species you're you're
here new this year new this bium or they
moved from somewhere else yeah we well I
think we had was it 100 or
150,000 as part of that grant program
for towns to apply for the invasive
species we re we reimburse towns
yeah yeah that's like Japanese not weed
and japanes which
is
horrifying
yeah I can never remember that Buri I
don't but it's something that wasn't
being done before that is correct better
sweep I don't know I can I can never
remember
Bittersweet yeah tree tree of Heaven is
another
one such a problem I just have this
block I think we talked about that the
last time so this is this is there that
was a newly funded position uh a while
ago so we do have one more person in
that division than we than we had the
previous
banian um we seen much bird
flu we have not seen much bird flu um
we have only seen it really in people
that are like sanctuaries or rescues and
they might have a pond and then a wild
goose flies in and then it it's and it
it is serious in that um because of the
quarantine zones uh hubard Farms which
is a international breeder of poultry
they can get up to
$150 per chick now for their specialty
Birds uh yeah it actually cost them sign
significant and I'm talking a couple
million dollars of sales because this
one little Sanctuary was in their
quarantine Zone and Japan would not take
the uh anything in from from New
Hampshire
but
neighbors what's the division of
regulatory Serv
services that is the uh division that
deals with
um the U generally what is it Gap um
they deal with the seed registration
which was a a big problem last year once
we divested ourselves of doing um
organic inspections we found out that
New Hampshire had become a Dumping
Ground for expired seeds such as grass
seeds so you bought your grass seed and
it didn't Sprout you thought it was
because you didn't water it enough or
you watered it too much or whatever it's
probably because it had
expired um we collected over uh $100,000
in fines in that area we had issued
about a quarter million dollars in fin
just trying to get some attention but it
was still significant that we actually
did collect because they were just
moving the stuff all over the place can
I send my water bill to you to get
reimbursed
no but it's something where you hadn't
been spending much at all right and it's
it's really growing page
217 two that should have that should be
less from the general fund because we'
shifted so much no not well some more
from the general fund but also from
217 but in in
2024 it was only a $166,000 thing and
something looking
at
regulatory
yes um
yeah so is those matching that's because
the oh is this oh this is fsma isn't it
no that's not fsma no
okay we have been drawing down
accounting unit
2605 which is one of our dedicated fund
accounts and by the end of this
bium that account is not going to be
sustainable the way we're drawing
funds down
so a lot of that cost was in previous bu
and then we absorbed it into 2605 which
is the product was called the product
scale testing fund now it's
Agricultural Product regulatory
fund so we're trying to shift that some
of that fund there there are no new
positions in the well obviously yeah and
which those positions used to be in that
accounting unit but now are in
that all right all right so we will
consider your um your fee fee
suggestions we like those I think all
right would would you like me to uh who
would you like me to send chapter and
verse to yeah uh you can do that to Jack
and he'll get it to us yeah and um I
don't know if you have any house built
you nothing oh okay well this this would
be all this fee stuff will will become
too right okay so we may or may not ask
you back but thank you very
right yes
okay all right so we've saved the best
for
last
fortunately I
know they
hiding yeah because these guys have in
house build
one 131
[Laughter]
Pages
yeah so we are not going to go Page by
page I don't think maybe that's why they
have so many page but um let's go to
oh and welcome
commissioner thank you we have a hand
out too
good please is a committee yes
please all right so let's look at this
page
here
okay so I'll just tell you one of the
things we're we do is as we look at um
spending
on uh 20 2019 versus
2025 right to see what's the progress in
spending and you have one of the more
unusual
lines in that over those six years your
general fund spending went down
3% but your total
68% so I don't know what you're if you
if I don't know if that's doing
something right or wrong I I don't know
but it's it's very unusual me you like
it so if it pleases the chair I can I
can uh I can address that up up front a
little at least some of that so
obviously from 2019 to now A lot's
happened
and uh we received significant amounts
of arpa money for water and waste water
infrastructure uh the infrastructure
Bill uh was over a 5year period which is
still continuing added uh almost a half
a billion dollars in water and
wastewater struct uh infrastructure so I
I'll let in a moment once I'm done given
the the broad brush uh Susan Carlson I'm
sure can elaborate but uh that's a big
chunk of that increase right so and
that's a sign of post postco a lot of
money was injected into infrastructure
so that's
obviously we have roughly 200 programs
or so so there's a lot of moving Parts
within there but those are the big
ticket items that are probably driving
that if that makes sense so so okay um
okay yeah go ahead with the why don't
you do the presentation yeah so if I may
before briefly I'm GNA yeah I'll be
really brief and then I'll I'll hand
over for the presentation for uh our
chief operating officer Susan Carlson
again I'm Bob Scott uh happy to be back
again um
some items I want to note so obviously
now we're talking about the the
governor's budget last time we were here
we weren't able to talk freely about
that uh I will I will say context before
two items in the governor's budget one
which was the governor Governor's uh
initiative to on permit consolidation
which is in house bill one and two and I
know we'll be back next Friday to
discuss that I assume in more detail yes
and the addition of some uh funds in Dam
safety program in Le of a larger fee
increase uh before that we had roughly
uh an 11% reduction uh in general funds
after those two items were were entered
in we're we're now at roughly a 7%
reduction um I also want to note and I
think we did this in our last
presentation of the roughly uh B
basically half almost of the 7% we have
remaining in general funds is the state
aid grant program uh there's a slide on
that that that Sue Carlson and and uh we
we can go through and again that's I do
want to note that uh that
program with the existing Wastewater
projects that have already been entered
into that program and again this is a
Debt Service payment over 20 or so years
uh without adding any additional waste R
treatment plants and if we were to pay
all that debt services to that's $140
million so I just want to people to have
some context of that program and where
where that goes and that's assuming
funds availability of course so explain
that I'm not sure I understand so this
again there's a slide on this so you
know which page we want to go right
there okay
yeah should be page is it 10 um it's
sure whatever the chair desires yeah um
just so you understand what the
commissioner just said um state aid
grant programs for Wastewater um when we
make an award we then pay our 20% on
their Debt Service most communities have
a 20-year Debt Service schedule right
now on our existing grants that we have
made we have Debt Service payments going
out to 2052
and those going out to 2052 total up to
slightly less than $140 million it's not
that we're making $140 million in
payments this year it's just over over
the next 30 year uh 20 plus 30 20 plus
years we we've already calculated
there's that liability sitting there
okay but but the annual is one of these
num one of these six million type
numbers or yeah uh let me let me go
through okay sure um the state aid grant
program is a general fund program um and
the waste water is the largest active um
program of state aid grants we have a
small landfill closure state aid grant
program we have a small public water
interconnection program both of those
programs we consider to be closed we're
not making any new Awards um like
landfills there's less than 10 years
left in payments and on the public water
systems there's maybe 15 years left of
payments and they're small dollars
Wastewater is an active grant
program um and as you know under arpa
and now under Bill communities are
receiving millions of dollars in federal
aid to do major Wastewater
projects now those Grant monies are not
funding
100% of that project they're funding a
proportional so towns are taking on debt
to make those those
improvements and as those projects
finish um we participate under statute
on 20% of The Debt Service that they
have once the project is
complete so if the city of Manchester
has a $12 million project they get $6
million in funding from federal grants
or other sources then they have a bond
of $6 million we contribute 20% on that
remaining $6 million of bond
up until recently the state aid grant
program in the budget has been in a
county unit
a,3 and it is had received an
appropriation in the operating budget
over the last few years or last few
bium funding has in the budget has been
erratic a lot of the funding is now in
hb2 or in some cases is coming in a
separate
bill currently I think we have such a
bill yes yes you
do um currently um we have funding in
that accounting unit coming from two
sources one is House Bill
395 which was passed in the 22 session
which provided us funding in FY 23 and
FY
24 then in HB 2 from the 23 session we
received a lump sum of $27.9 million but
it was appropriated to us as a 23
appropriation not as a 24 appropriation
so it doesn't show up in our 24 budget
or our 25 budget as an appropriation it
just a huge balance for
it what we have been doing a dedicated
fund or no it's not a dedicated fund it
is just a general fund appropriation
it's just on the books it's on the books
it's a nonap and it's non- lapsing right
okay so what we've been doing because we
have these two pots of money and just to
give you an idea we are currently paying
on
projects so that is the population that
we're currently paying
on what we have been doing
with the HB 398 money is as communities
submit their applications for state aid
grants we've been making the initial
award using that
appropriation then once we get past that
first year then that we call that at
that point we then call it okay that's
maintenance and then we start paying the
second year onward out of the hb2
money that's what this table is showing
you so right
now under these two pots of money that
sit in one accounting unit we started
the
2425 bium was $7.8 million of HB 398
money and we started
2425 with 27.9 million of what I call
the hb2
money during 24 and
25 we have dispersed out
and made new Awards and we have pending
um in our program right now an
additional I think six to nine
applications that we could be making new
Awards on right
now in addition to that um we have been
making what we call our maintenance
payments we made um $ 10.8 Million last
year and we're going to be making $10.3
million this year in payment inside the
hb2 money which will leave us $6.1
million left of the HB 398 money and
$6.6 million in change of the hb2
money forecasting out for 26 and 27
under HB
398 we have potentially 12 new 12 to 15
new Awards we're intend we think we
might be making in
26 and then another
15 new Awards we might be making in
27 with those estimated payments that
would be spend another approximately $3
million we would end the 27 26 27 bym
with 3.1 million of that HB 398 money
left on the hb2
money what I've done is in 26 we have
defined maintenance payments of of
10.2 um um new payments estimated new
payments from any new Awards we make
this year of 700,000 so we our payments
would be $1
million our current budget for 26 is
million um which leaves a difference of
2.1 in 27 our maintenance payments would
be
9.7 plus another 700,000 from the 25
Awards Plus plus 1.2 million of
additional funds and payments that came
from 26 Awards so we'd be at
11.6 the budget is currently sitting at
8.6 a difference of 3 million we started
the 20 if we'd start the 2627 by Anum
with a $6.6 million excess you subtract
out the two differences for 26 and 27 we
will end the 27 vium with a balance of
that original hb2 Money of 1 Point
slightly under 1.5
million so that is where we stand on on
state aid grants at a very high level so
if I looked in house bill one I would
find
8.98 for 26 and
8605 for 27 right and if I wanted to I
could take the extra
4.6 that I see at the bottom of the page
age and lower those two amounts you
could
okay I will tell you um just so you
understand what we're
forecasting is we are looking at like I
said 15 new Awards in
26 15 new Awards or actually upwards of
15 to 30 new Awards in 27 and additional
30 new Awards in 28
what we are forecasting out is as this
Opa money has been spent and as all
these waste water projects are now being
completed communities have this volume
of projects that they will be coming
into us for State a grant funding so the
demand will be going
up okay now you said it's all Wastewater
I thought some of these are freshwater
no Wastewater is sewer sewer right yeah
there's no drinking water in this
program oh but there is somewhere else
we have a small public water
interconnection state aid grant program
but that's a closed program there's no
new no new general fund Awards in that
if you read the statute for that it was
based on an EPA change and regulations
from the
90s that's all done okay
but then there's other federal grants oh
there's a lot of other federal grants
for public water system I and then
there's a drinking water groundwater
trust fund several several there's a lot
of there's all kinds of other money
right yes is there
other such things for Wastewater or not
no well there is the srf Loan program
okay that and um some of the and with
the bill money that comes as
supplemental bill money there is
additional money there but generally
there are not grants for wastewater
treatment
systems so again the difference here is
the state aid grant program is that
after the fact you've already built your
plant you commissioned it and now the
state is helping to pay debt service up
to 20% uh the state revolving Loan Fund
and the other funds we're talking about
are upfront and during construction to
to get it to get it going so it's on the
other side if you will but we tell them
before they build it that this money is
available or not uh that would be I'm
sure represent Buco would have a lot of
opinions on this but I would argue at
least from our staff given that starting
under Governor Lynch this program has
stopped and started stopped and started
multiple times we try to assure them
that this is not a guarantee I see and
it's subject to availability of funds
others say different but so if I turn to
page
733 um and I see that you're you're
budgeting 27 million of General funds
per
year we've just seen eight of that eight
and a half or something each year is
saying can you say that question so on
page
733 uh I look at General funds yeah
27. 385 358 and 27.8
35 right um you already what you just
told me is roughly 8 to n million of
that yes right so we haven't yet heard
about 18 million or so of that right or
yes yeah in each year yes yes okay good
all right representative Griffin so that
brings me to the question of that $18
million is any of that matching
funds
yes it it
um I can't give you an exact number of
how much of our general funds is
matching but um I would I would have to
get back to you with an exact number I
wouldn't want to guess can you guess
about uh she doesn't want it she doesn't
we're trying to we're trying to get the
grasp of the picture it doesn't have to
be perfect it doesn't have to be to the
penny um I would say I would be guessing
at 20 to 25% but I would want to i'
really want to confirm that well let me
let me ask a question like if you were
to lose 15 million of General funds what
impact would it have on you and how much
of that would you manage to to use
I
um we would probably
lose
75% of our general fund programs and um
I would doubt we could
replace any of that with federal
funds um our primary Federal Agency for
our funding is EPA
um and we have no idea what is happening
to epa's budget going
forward well let let me rephrase the
question other than those
funds other than those funds that are
required for matching funds and are
already committed to the Wastewater
thing whatever is
left what what what would the impact of
um well
um we would probably
lose
um we would lose our circular
maintenance program which is the program
that manages the former Federal super
fund
sites um we would lose our Solid Waste
Management program we would lose um um
lakes and rivers management we would
lose shellfish we would lose Dam
operations um we would lose um
commissioner's office um maybe not
a um we probably would lose the majority
of our administrative staff we would
probably lose
geology um we would lose a yeah most
most of our programs yeah we'd have to
cut programs I don't see federal funds
able to so here is the is the position
that the finance finds itself
in uh we have to make cuts and the cuts
are going to be
significant and
uh we we want to know what damage we're
going to
do
so because there is I'm sure there'll be
some damage because the revenue
shortfall is large enough that there're
going to be Cuts Here There and
Everywhere pretty much uh the the uh
Governor's 4% isn't isn't going to be
sufficient so I'm trying to get a grasp
on on what the impact of those cuts is
going to be to in each
agency so any light you can shed on that
yeah when you talk about like your
office for
example would don't Federal Grant allow
some some fraction of them to be used
for administration and things like that
yeah usually it's the other way around
we're matching with some with our staff
time usually but good um I
see the administration and support
account which is the first account in
our budget um as you can see um we
collect um 47% of that uh county unit um
through the indirect cost proposals and
that's how we recapture
a good portion of the admin support the
commissioner's office um is not um is in
the Statewide indirect cost pool which
um gets collected part of the what they
call the swap dollars and it goes right
to administrative Services the
Department of administra Services so um
but we don't we don't capture it on our
budget the commissioner's office is 100%
General fund gotcha all right
representative Griffin again and then
representative Wy thank you Mr chair
just a follow-up question obviously when
you inspect dams you get you get U
Revenue when you do septic systems you
get Revenue you you you receive revenue
for most of what you
do uh is that Revenue now all going to
the general fund or is it going into an
inter agency fund is it in other funds
uh for the ones you mentioned those are
going to for those programs I will say
um and you know our view is Fe fee for
service makes a lot of sense uh is uh
yeah so we have some projected increases
in those fees as well and house bill to
uh moving forward but are are you
retaining those fees to cover your cost
yes yes so you you you not necessarily
wouldn't lose everything that you well
those programs are already um on the
budget as other funds they are not on
the budget as general funds yeah so
they've already they're they're not in
our $27 million well like inspection of
dams that you mentioned that you lose
aren't there significant fees when when
when somebody owns a dam and has it
inspected uh I would arue know they're
not significant fees but we're we're
trying to increase them but but but to
answer your earlier question I mean the
only program that comes to mind in in uh
director set behind me but the solid
waste program to the extent they have
fees that goes into the general fund and
then back to staff again so it's so
that's anyways so so they do have fees
but it's not enough to cover but it goes
to the general funds if that answers
your question so representative eel
wants to add some fees to that I think
any she does yes she does okay
representative wer what we found is that
a lot of the fees we charge
been changed for 20 years sometimes
longer and and you know everything else
has gone up in 20 years AG s them by the
price of eggs we could triple
them anyway it's it's a way to keep from
having to cut so deep yes if we bring it
in more in fees that would make up for
the general fund that we have to
increase or I see you've already taken a
considerable cut but it it would ease
some of the pain for your agency if
places you collected fees you went back
and looked whoa that one's that's been
the same since
2010 well you you bring about up the the
damn safety program so right now what's
proposed there's going to be a very
modest fee increase and it will be
augmented with General funds to not have
a big fee increase as an example I
suspect that may be what you're getting
at representative um the other thing
we've we've been you'll see some
language from us on you're right we have
some fees for instance has increased
since
2009 and things have cost more you know
the cost of living so the other thing
we've we've we have some language we've
thrown out is okay set the fee and then
have a a CPI attached to that and if
there's and if if uh you know with
approval from the commissioner we would
go to the the uh fiscal committee for
example to implement but it would at
least allow
not have that huge huge sticker shock
from going from 2009 and then oh my God
the fe's doubling we've already had the
big sticker shock and gasoline eggs
groceries everything
so I mean if it means we don't have to
reduce your operations as much and I'd
appreciate it if you do an analysis of
all your fees give us an idea if you
went up by just
CPI how much more would we bring in that
we wouldn't have to worry about you got
to cut this and you got to cut that okay
that's people have got to expect it
they' got it everywhere else yeah that's
very much in line with what we'd be
interested in I
also for a later discussion we fit
similar discussion on dams right now
dams are not being funded in an
appropriate way sustainable way in my
opinion uh and and I think the answer is
ultimately some kind of fee for service
right I even saw a
suggestion I know the Waterfront people
would hate it
but stick something on each of them you
know they all want to get involved in
hey you can't draw down my damn I won't
be able to take my boat out you know so
okay we may have heard that yes all
right representative
Ms thank you Mr chair and thank you uh
for coming in again um how much how much
money is there in this budget for pest
remediation including at um at director
wisit knows I'm um interested in
landfills at at at
landfills um and then my second question
is uh related to that if we were to make
significant Cuts in general funding uh
resources available to you what would
the implications be on the availability
of federal funding to support those
efforts so I'll let Sue I'll give I'll
buy some time for Sue Carlson here to to
to develop an answer but a few things
and again as uh ripson of wer pointed
out we do have I I would want to point
to to our summary on page page 11 of our
slide so that gives talks a little bit
of past but other things also so you
will see 55 million uh in 26 that's from
a a nationwide settlement that's our
expected amount coming to New Hampshire
I will put as a caveat I know that's not
where the representative was suggesting
that money has kind of been pre-
obligated to the water system so so the
past uh it it'll go to Water Systems who
have incurred a cost to remediate
pasas uh the good news is between here's
my commercial uh between the the good
efforts of the depart Department of
Justice here and and and my my staff
proportionately New Hampshire is going
to get more out of the settlement than
any other state state that's the good
news the bad news this is going to be
Pennies on a dollar for what they've
incurred so you you may hear some
rumbling but at least we've you know
we're trying we also you may remember in
pass by anys uh we had uh we were
allowed $55 million in
bonding uh for for
p uh that's still there uh but bottom
line is we have a mix of General funds
to address pasas uh drinking water
ground water trust fund has has kicked
in in some some places and some of the
federal money I mentioned the the
infrastructure money uh under the title
of emerging contaminants it's kind of a
broad thing we're able to use also so
there there is a mix of money I will add
unfortunately the just like I mentioned
for the Water Systems the the impact is
still larger than the amount of money
but there are there are some so I don't
I don't have a figure for all the
general funds I don't know if sue if I
give you enough time if not I'll start
tap dancing how's
that
um um
717 um account
4728 that is our emerging contaminate
fund that is primarily um the one we're
talking about and as you can see if you
look at 26 you can um see it jumps up to
$86 million that's primarily because
we've we've asked and the governor and
nicely included it in her operating
budget to put in $55 million of the um
potential set of the settlement funds we
intend to receive on 3 A.M that's the
biggest single piece uh but that is the
program that where we do the majority of
the PS work as the commissioner said um
there is um under our um drinking water
groundwater Bureau um we are getting
approximately $9 million a year dealing
with emerging
contaminants um and
um and um and if you look at if you flip
719 this is the account um this is our
uh past response
fund this is primarily being funded as
as the commissioner said out of a $50
million Capital
appropriation um we have been granted um
some additional funds over the past
years of supplemental General funds put
in here at this account what the budget
is actually set based on what we have
available of that Bond
money so just so there's really no
connection between either of these and
kind of general fund Federal fund
matching formulas no okay thank
three so just in in general
um I don't remember when we budgeted the
previous bium that that there was a two
210 million increase from 70 24 to
25 so things must have happened in the
meantime right so this is the deceiving
part of the way this budget is is
structured 24 is actual expenditures
it's not Appropriations and it also
doesn't reflect incumbrances
um when we ended fiscal year
24 what is not reflected in this number
is we had $44 million in encumbrances
wow okay most of that in um grants and
Loans okay and so new ones in 2024 or
just total total combination and that's
excluding ARA
money um so it's very deceiving when you
look at our budget versus our expend
because our expend is is not keeping it
it looks like we're not spending our
budget but in reality we are using you
know nearly 98% of our budget because we
have
encumbrances um the the thing with
loans um that most people are unaware of
when we give out like a a a clean water
loan or a drinking water loan the
average time it takes from the time we
issue that loan till it is spent by the
communities averages between three to
five
years so we have money you know we have
to budget to be able to issue those
loans but the spend doesn't match the
year we issue you saying
M okay if I collaborate it's not like we
issue a check to a community and walk
away they they you know especially if
there's Federal feral strings attached
you know uh by American Davis bacon wage
Etc we have to monitor all that but also
they have to meet their engineering
design before we can we pay them so
basically we pay they remit saying hey
we've me this Milestone we have to have
our engineering staff validated our
accounting staff make sure all that
things have been met and then we pay so
it's it would be nice if it was just
issue a check and and walk away but
there's quite a tail to this and
obviously loans that are 20 years or
more have to be serviced also so it's so
how about the way money comes from the
federal government is
it that we op you know you say you have
400 million in incumbrances obviously a
lot of that is going to be paid for with
money that comes from the federal
government is that the federal
government has already sent us that
money or that they're obligated to send
us when when yes it comes due Etc the
feds with the exception of ARA the feds
never Advance US money okay um is and
how we have our loans set up is As the
commissioner said um the towns will draw
on their loans when they've dispersed
funds we always disperse on a
reimbursement basis the federal
government gen always disperses on a
reimbursement basis okay so essentially
when we cut a check let's say the city
of Manchester they come in with a
reimburse request for $1.2 million we're
we're committing federal funds Federal
Loan to that we will disperse them
within 24 hours of dispersing that funds
to the city of Manchester we've
submitted a request to the feds to draw
that money out of the federal government
okay so the the actual from 2024 of 47
million of federal funds that's what
they actually sent us in 2024 yes yes
okay plus or minus some receivables okay
but the
187 we're putting in here for fiscal
year 25 25 includes some money that they
won't send us in
25 but they promis to send us later when
the spending happens yes okay okay so
the amount they they're actually going
to send us in 25 is probably somewhere
in between those two numbers yeah okay
yeah it will as fast as we can spend it
that's how how much we'll get back from
them gotcha okay but but they are
obligated so we can make promises to
town we don't issue grants until we have
an award in hand gotcha now I can't
count for if the federal government
decides to resend
things
sure never heard of all right
representative evil yeah so if you look
at the general fund line on page
733 the 2025 adjusted authorized took
quite a dip there um so what accounted
for that that is because the state aid
grant money was not part of our
appropriation for 25 that was the money
we received actually appropriated in
23 as you can see we spent $27 million
in 24 that reflects actual um State a
grant dispersements that aren't
reflected in the budget it's that page
we went over in detail
yeah um but you basically held the line
on general fund spending for
2627 yes we've tried to right okay Mr my
apologies back I understand yes he's not
being Rudy at previous
commitment okay all right so let's um
why don't we go to the rest of your
presentation if there's any oh that's
right we were doing a presentation
so now that we kind of got the big
picture I think right so again if
anything if page 11 of our presentation
is probably the most important before I
I let Sue go through this I do want to
add that we will will be asking for
probably next week I guess a technical
Amendment to the fishing game portion of
the governor's uh pering consolidation
uh just just to put give you a heads up
on that okay yeah I think we're doing um
Friday Friday
we have House Bill too well we might
have it other days too but yeah
okay um Mr chair do you think it would
be possible to have the fees that uh
chair Wier requested for potential
increases by Friday so just to uh make
sure we understand the homework
assignment so it would be areas where
General funds could we could alleviate
General funds with a fee increase does
that sound right yes
I think we can have that by You Want by
One well no I I just whatever these guys
say
Okay um and and just so you know um
before I forget I do have a few minor
technical corrections I would like to
present before this committee um
sometime House Bill one things House
Bill one things yes okay are they in the
here or no uh no they're I I separated
them
out um because I wanted to talk about
them and then give the LBA the I see the
pages gotcha
um to make it easier all right well why
don't we finish page 11 and then then we
that
um essentially what I would like to do
is kind of back up to page
I gave you
ex um I just I know we have presented
this pie chart before but I wanted to
give you this pie chart as it stands
using the governor's budget numbers
because um with the addition of the $55
million our our funding splits have
changed um as you can see in this source
of funds the two blue pieces of the pie
represent our state revolving loan
programs both the federal funds and the
repayment funds together they add up to
37% of our entire operating budget all
other federal funds at 57 million
account for
14% all all of our other fee accounts
other than srf fees and drinking water
groundwater trust add up to another 78
million or 20% of our operating budget
the trust fund is sitting now at $86
million or 22% of our operating budget
with our general fund down to 7% of our
operating budget so I just wanted you to
see the mix of funds that we have um if
you flip over to page um so the the
drinking water groundwater trust funds
this 86 million we expect that to be
mostly a one-time payment in 55 million
of it is that onetime thing it's
normally you know $20 million and that's
not going to be repeated or if it is we
have no idea that it would yeah we we do
not know how much additional settlement
money we might receive great I think you
anticipate more lawsuits though yes this
is only part of that
settlement okay um as far as uses of
funds go
um 74% of our budget for 26 um is is
literally going out the door in the form
of Grants reimbursement loans and
contracts only those three little blue
devices add up to the operating expenses
that literally stay in house and even a
portion of those um go to the other
state agencies uh in the um for our
budget so um just to give you an idea
how much of our budget does not stay in
house
um what I've done on the following
slide um is just to break down an
analysis comparing um our 26 and 27
budgets versus against the Baseline of
25 as you can see um our grants are down
um by a million in 26 and 2 million 27
loans have dropped significantly by $46
million um reimbursements overall
because we have a number of programs
that do reimbursements went up
significantly which is primarily the $50
million
$55 million um for um the pest
reimbursements offset by decreases in
other programs so what you mean here is
this would be money going to Water
Systems who would put in past filters is
that a
reimbursement past remediation work okay
okay so it could be a water system it
could be a water system putting
treatment on or given extending water
pipes to some
well I see
gotcha um
contracts um went from 25 to 26 went up
about $2 million in um 26 and then
dropped $5 million in 27 the difference
is because we front loaded some
contracts into
26 salary and benefits went up
approximately 3% per year which is about
the average we have um then inter agency
transfer stayed relatively flat inter
agency transfers for us is the payments
we make to administrative services for
building rent um
doit um for services T justice EAP those
types of EX those types of cost okay so
let's um as long as we're on salary and
benefits here of these 500 employees how
many are
vacant we have 47 vacant full-time
positions okay and um funded or unfunded
funded
okay and you're so you're but you're in
a hiring freeze right so you're not
yes corre yes yeah okay not actively
looking
general which it might I guess you know
on some cases anyway okay obviously to
the extent we make large Cuts we'll do
less with less right so that'll mean
less services so I just you know state
in the
obvious
okay yeah
but the bottom line here is that you've
re your percent change is minus
18% on your page that you just went
through here I mean so you've already
done some
cutting
um yeah yes 27 is down over
26 um if I was to go back to the
presentation from the agency phase you
would have seen a cut in both years um
26 is actually showing an increase but
yes
okay um I guess it would be interesting
to us to have this kind of
detail but on the general fund part
January
MH um we we do have some part-time staff
not a great deal um it also fluctuates
um to by you know vacancy rates as well
yeah well you can yeah so representative
Griffin has a has a
request yeah I wonder if you could um
get us a list
of the uh federal funds that require
matching funds yep and the source or
possible sources of those matching funds
MH and in other words if if uh matching
funds could be paid by other revenues or
agency revenues rather than
General revenues general fund revenues
yep I think it would be helpful to
you um on the next slide um it's
we what I did was re um slice and dice
the information just by sources of funds
so using 25 is the Baseline um as you
can see 26 General funds went up by 7.9
million obviously that is nearly all of
the majority of that is because we put
state aid grants back on the budget yes
yes okay um federal funds the srf
programs um we lowered the funding from
25 to
26 um for the F srf what we did was kind
of what I did was kind of right siiz the
budget for 26 27 bringing it down we had
received a lot of extra bill money in 24
and 25 so I brought those budgets down
um for 26 27 all other federal funds we
is that because of the loan requests
weren't as big is that what you mean or
I was trying to adhere to what the
governor asked us to do to rze the
budget so I brought those down knowing
that if
we if we actually um end up spending
higher than what we have budgeted we can
go back in front of fiscal to ask for
additional funds okay um um
other Federal all other Federal programs
had a small
change um the srf fee count um it was
basically we had a very small change we
flatlined it pretty well the trust fund
obviously saw a big spike in 26 and an
offset in
27 and all other of our fee accounts we
took a reduction of $8 million each
year and a lot of that is because of the
mtbe program is that particular program
is is ending its funding oh okay um I
did as a matter of course on the next
slide show you what the changes were
from our agency phase to the governor's
phase I thought that might be
interesting information for
you um as you can see we lowered some
Grant lines primarily that was um in the
the side grants we also lowered the the
grants for the lake restoration
program loans didn't change
reimbursements obviously went up by the
million contracts and operating expenses
changed slightly because um in the
governor's phase we took the two new
programs um from fishing game and Dancer
we added those that also increased our
salary and benefits because it was eight
positions we were putting on um um and
it also increased slightly inter agency
transfers and you'll note the uh the air
permit fee so we were in the time of
surplus uh we were getting a general
fund contribution so we didn't need to
raise our the fees on air
permitting uh the uh stationary sources
in the State
uh that's being removed and will you
know that will go into the fee increases
instead which sounds like it's in line
with the questions ask
right and on the next slide again this
shows based on funding category it's the
difference between the H andc phase and
the governor's phase as you can see um
we did another $2 million reduction in
general funds overall our srf federal
changed just slightly some of these very
small dollars um changes occurred
because um in the governor's phas
there was a revamping of the benefit
rates and this hit across all
agencies um and we saw um and that's
what the small dollars and other the
trust obviously was rounding that's 55
million we did move um between the
agency and the governor's phase we did
move one of our major programs from
General funds to fees and that was the
wetlands Administration program um we
took that off the general fund entirely
fee um the commissioner has already gone
over um this um the next the two slides
one is the the overall changes that we
have had um and then slide um slide 11
was the we've already discussed which
was the change in the state aid grants
um I did hand out to Jack the few
technical Corrections um we are asking
for in this
budget um one of them is our L is our
account called River restoration dam
removal we just were notified that we
are getting some um grant money from
charitable foundations to do um removal
on the gonik dam and getting some Grant
funds to do some stre Crossing fixtur um
fixes so that we'd like to add about 233
$236,000 a year for that program that
none of that is General
funds the second request is the lrm data
check
tool as dncr talked to you earlier this
afternoon about
positions in the governor's budget there
were four positions from dncr that was
moved to our
budget the way we um three of the
original four positions that were sent
to us we are sending back to dncr and we
are getting one nobody wants them dncr
wants them um okay and and dncr is
sending us one position the net change
to that account is a a reduction of
$212,000 in in um 26 and
27 um and then my last request for a
change is on the $55
million um I forgot to ask the
governor's office if they would kindly
put a footnote on this one particular
class line to make it the appropriation
non laap for the
bium we hope just we hope to disperse it
all in 26 but in case we can't disperse
it all in 26 I'd like to roll that class
into
27 yes that is my number
two yeah and as I mentioned we'll have
an additional one if we'd like to do
regarding the the governor's permitting
consolidation similar to what we're
doing with dmtr we have similar
discussions going on with with fishing
game uh and we should be able to do that
early next week where right where would
it lapse too if it's not a lapse per se
it would roll into the fund it's not a
lapse it's not a lapse lapse I didn't
know what how exactly how to word it I
just needed the appropriation not
to expire at the end in June 30th
26 yes it's just good for the banum if
you have better language I would clearly
take it don't SP it
in6 yes
yes I just didn't want to have to come
back in
27 because we do not know the exact date
we will be receiving this money um I
just want to make sure well what the
what the restrictions are on this from
the federal government and how we spend
it we're talking the lawsuit so yes the
laws the federal government's not
involved with this so this is this is uh
individual State and states and Water
Systems have sued uh 3M and and Pont
this is part of the a global settlement
through the court so this I'm not sure I
see any way the federal government does
anything with but but then the court is
there some settlement agreement yes yeah
yes and that tells you how to spend it
right so there's a complex formula of
impacted Water Systems which is what
staff and and doj orchestrated with them
uh and the dispers it's being dispersed
over in in in blocks over a time frame
so it's it's and the money has yet to
move so we're still not quite sure when
and how it's going to get to us but I
mean have those Water Systems already
put in the equipment to solve the
problem or is it were we giving them
money ahead of time uh we're only giving
money to those who expense had expenses
related to remediating so so if that
makes sense yeah so so some may not even
know or or I guess everybody is testing
right now so everybody knows we in the
past year year and a half we've had to
do all new rounds of testing with water
systems more than you want to know
probably but we proactively tested work
with all the Water Systems to get this
data because normally we're in our
regulatory scheme we require certain
testing and We Gather that the court and
I think well meaning but they didn't
quite understand how that's normally
gathered want needed it in a different
way and a different format so we had to
do all new testing in order to gather
all this data for all our water systems
that have had even uh detections of
pasas which was a huge amount of work by
the way um I I don't know if I answered
your question or confused well and some
of it some of this money is going to go
to people with individual Wells yes or
no no this this particular settlement is
just for Public Water Systems as
representative Vil mentioned we are
still in court and I think this will be
years away with the Department of
Justice on our actions in to address
contamination for private Wells so
that's still out there kind of sort of
maybe someday this settlement is for
Public Water Systems only because I've
heard some people say they've gotten
systems for their homes from uh from
some kind of programs that you have yes
there's multiple for for homes there's
multiple two major programs so uh within
the St Goan consent decree area it's
incumbent upon stco Bain to provide
those type of services or water lines
outside that area we've provided uh with
some of this past money we've talked
about we've made available a rebate
program where if your private private
well has been contaminated you can get
up to $5,000 to put a point of entry
treatment in a home treatment system or
if you're near enough to a water line
where it makes sense will give you up to
10 you can get up to $110,000 rebate
to connect to that water water line so
that's those are the two programs you're
probably heard of and where did that
money come from again the that money is
a combination of uh general fund
Appropriations from pass by inum uh
again in the capital budget we were we
we got uh bonding Authority for up to
$50 million to address that uh there has
been some drinking water groundwater
trust fund money put into that as well
so there's kind of a combination there I
see
okay um and what about that includes
testing too or no yes we we've covered
some testing costs also but there's
there's again there's a lot of putts of
money is also and then not for actually
it is now we have again this bill money
I I talked about this huge influx of
money for infrastructure that emerging
contaminant monies it's technically a
loan but you you can get a a loan if
you're contaminated but you get
100% forgiveness so it's a loan I guess
but but anyways to me it's a grant but
anyway so so there's funds on that too
and we've been able to work with Senator
Shaheen's office to get that to apply
this last round to private Wells as well
so that was we really pushed for that
because we have so we have you know
roughly half our population is on
private Wells and we wanted to make sure
we're taking care of them also I would
assume very small fraction of them have
ever tested right so I don't have those
figures I don't know I mean probably
they've tested for our but we have our
whole program that we've been reaching
out if we have if we have CA believe
people are above the state standard
we've proactively gone out we've done a
lot of lot of testing over the years uh
to the point where I'll brag on my staff
a little bit if you look at we've seen
maps of the country where testing has
been done in some areas of the countries
it's just spots here and there New
Hampshire is basically filled in and
we're literally more than the rest of
the country combined so that's the
amount of sampling we've done so I see
okay representative Ms just a quick
question on that um
that 3M U settlement fund you you
mentioned that it's uh intended
primarily for publicly owned Water
Systems does that mean a system owned by
the town or city I mean in in the on the
Sea Coast I mean our water system is
privately owned it's a it's a company
that owns it it's actually again this is
an EPA definition so it's it's a water
system that serves the public serves the
public okay so it it could be actually
it could be uh aquar your Dunkin Donuts
for instance gotcha okay thank you but
it also includes those
also other questions represent LE I just
had a question for you one of your
questions was you wanted a better
breakdown of the general fund use but I
I don't think I get Jerry's correct for
the minutes did you want a breakdown of
General funds to get federal funds or
matching funds was that party that's a
secondary question yeah okay okay I just
want to make sure I had that
thanks representative evil well just
because we've had so many conversations
I just want to go back to what your your
beginning points were you've already cut
General funds coming into this by 11% is
that correct and then what you said was
that when going through the governor's
phase she added some money for the for
the dams
and was one of fishing game fishing game
for the fishing game um how just how
much for the dams I'm just curious um
they gave us
um
approximately me it was 10 million in
the capital get the exact number um in
20 six they gave it
68,000 and in 27 they gave us 670,000
and that was in Le of a fee increase Yes
And to clarify for representative
leechman that the we're not talking the
capital budget to repair dams we were
talking the dam safety program to
monitor in the operating budget but you
just got 10 in the
capital yeah the capital is repair these
are for the folks that go out and
inspect all
days so the way I heard it is when you
claim to cut General funds it's from the
agency phase right to the governor's
phase so so it's from what you wanted to
what you got as opposed to from last
year or from you
know we were we were given a a set
dollar amount in the in the for the
agency phase and we brought our funding
down to that level um and then we
received an ADD additional reduction in
the governor's pH right okay and then
they gave us new things to do follow
represent yeah the chair because I was
looking at the same thing because under
the um comparison on page 10 it shows a
7% reduction in general funds but then
over on page 11 it shows a 10% so I no
you just said 11% to representative evil
so just a little curious how those all
work
together see on page 10 it talks about a
7% change and then on the budget changes
10% all right um the agency agency phase
right yeah
um that
the table on page um 10 is the net
number we what we did was we took this
cut and then we were
offset we took a cut on our
Appropriations and then the governor
then gave us back some money in terms of
the um lrm Wildlife program and then
additional funding for dam for the dams
so you and then you went with her
additions you went to seven yes corre
okay right I didn't it wasn't that clear
to me but I'm a little slow on the take
up sometimes
M all right I think it's four o'clock we
should get some
sleep yeah especially you Mr especially
me y have a nice weekend and we're gonna
[Laughter]
53 years I think we already did that a
few weeks
you yeah we we we saw somebody else
chasing yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah a
good lady from the Secretary of State I
thought it was 45 or something you know
yeah I haven't hit I haven't hit rainy
but I started when I was 12 so I'm at 42
there you go
congratulations all right so we're going
to be back um next week Monday Wednesday
Friday at 10 at 10: each day right okay
can